this is Jocko podcast number 374 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
I found myself in a C-130 lumbering
through the sky at 20 000 feet one late
spring night
when you're inside an airplane or a
helicopter that's a sensation of height
is muted
as far as the physical senses are
concerned you might as well be standing
in a small wobbly room or sitting in an
uncomfortable chair
but once we reach the right altitude
I was in the tail standing on an open
ramp staring into a pitch black abyss
and getting ready to throw myself into
it
did I mention that I hate heights
the fear response is an interesting
thing there are some basic physiological
reactions common to most people an
increase in pulse and respiration
dilation of the pupils
but others are idiosyncratic mine
I yawn I know it sounds weird and I used
to think it was too but what I know now
know is that yawning is just my body's
way of trying to re-regulate my
breathing take in more oxygen and a set
and access my parasynthetic nervous
system
of course the outward appearance of this
suggests the complete opposite of fear
which is handy when you don't want
people to know that you're nervous
but I was I was nervous every time I got
ready to jump I was practicing the most
difficult level of of skydiving high
altitude high opening or hey ho
you jump from around 20 000 feet count
to four then pull the cord
the parachute opens at about 19 000 feet
which means there's a long flight to a
distant Landing Zone
this training is done during the day and
at night with nighttime proficiency
being the goal which is why I was
standing at the back of that C-130
yawning in the black sky
several things make jumping from that
height more difficult
one is how cold it is up there average
air temperature differentials are
approximately three degrees per thousand
feet this means that if it's reasonable
to 60 degrees when you board the
aircraft you can expect the air to be a
bone chilling Sub-Zero temperature when
you jump out
there's also very little oxygen at that
height at sea level the air is almost 21
oxygen at twenty thousand feet it
plummets to less than 10 percent
or they are that thin you're at risk of
altitude sickness
which includes a myriad of symptoms
ranging from dizziness fatigue and
headache to massive confusion shortness
of breath and complete loss of
consciousness
this means you have to jump with an
oxygen canister and mask and that's on
top of full combat gear ballistic helmet
and because it's pitch dark night vision
goggles
that's a lot of equipment to juggle
which only adds to the list of skills
needed to survive a hey ho jump
yet I'd mastered all those skills
I'd made dozens of hey ho jumps
yet my nerves quickened every time I
stood at that open ramp
and none of those skills mattered if I
couldn't force myself out of the damn
door
in times of high stress and great
discomfort skills Aren't Enough
that
is where attributes come in
that right there is an excerpt from a
book called the attributes 25 hidden
drivers of Optimal Performance written
by
Rich Divini and the book
focuses on uncovering attributes
required for success in any Endeavor and
also how to evaluate and improve those
attributes
and the author Rich Divini is a retired
seal officer
served over 20 years in the Navy
deployed over a dozen times
11 of those deployments or to Iraq or
Afghanistan
he served in leadership positions at
every level
and also ran the assessment and
selection for the maritime component
of the joint Special Operations Command
which we call jsoc and it's an honor to
have him with us here tonight to talk
about his experiences and Lessons
Learned and of course we'll dive into
these attributes Rich thanks for coming
down man thanks Jago honored to be here
yeah glad to have you uh I know we ran
into each other in some unfortunate
circumstances but glad we were able to
link up
um and
get the opportunity to pass on some of
these lessons some of these hard earned
lessons that you have which includes
being in a the most uncomfortable
position with gear strapped all over
your body on the back of a C-130 in the
middle of the night good times good time
uh let's let's just before we jump into
the book
um let's jump into just how you ended up
here how you ended up there yeah uh so
where were you born you're Connecticut
kid I'm a Connecticut kid and it's a
surprise it's actually surprising how
many uh Team guys that I discovered when
I went to Steel training how many guys
are from Connecticut yeah a lot of big
populists I don't know what it is maybe
something in the water I always found it
rare I don't know I would whenever I met
a guy from Connecticut I was like whoa
right on yeah all I know is that when I
first joined up within the first few
years I met at least a dozen or more
dudes from Connecticut did you ever hear
that thing that when they researched who
could make it through buds they were
trying to figure out the thing that they
figured out there was two things they
only improved the chance of making
through buds like almost almost a
immeasurable tiny amount but it was
wrestlers and people from New England
have you ever heard that I heard
wrestlers I didn't hear people from New
England I also heard rowers and I have a
theory on that one too but we can talk
what's your three on rowers so well it
says wrestlers and rowers and what I I
think one of the one of the primary
attributes required if there's one most
important attribute required to get
through buds it's compartmentalization
It's ability to assess your environment
immediately prioritize what you need to
focus on and then focus on that until
completion and so uh you think about a
rower and I never rode competitively but
I've talked to many routers a rower is
someone who's sitting in a boat and is
part of a team
and has to literally just row until they
puke and if they if they even break
their Rhythm for a second they mess up
the whole team so it's literally a
selfless sacrifice in in a in a team
effort that they just have to gut it out
until they're done I mean it is is kind
of one of the most intense
compartmentalization moments I think
what's the average length of one of
those races in time oh I have no I have
no idea uh they're doing 2 000 meters
I'm sure it's like sprinting in terms of
they have different uh difference uh
distances but none of them are are short
yeah you're gonna have to keep it
together for a long a longer period of
time and and two and two not to even dip
a little bit is going to affect the team
which is fascinating to me um and of
course wrestlers I think you know and I
would actually put any fighting
discipline into this category this idea
that you are
you are in a ring with another human so
it's a highly uncertain situation and uh
and you have to you have to
compartmentalize and you have to
basically adapt to everything you're
seeing and you are often being viewed by
by the external so to to give up in any
capacity is going to mean injury or
least or or I guess least uh or least
favorite embarrassment injury or
embarrassment so I think I think those
those Sports I talk about I I typically
don't talk about attributes in the
athletic Endeavors because most most
sports are fairly certain environments
uh other than a few and the fee that I
do talk about are fighting Sports
climbing in some cases uh rowing is
pretty certain but I think
compartmentalization is is definitely
affected in that one but Chuck yeah
um so you're born in Connecticut what'd
your parents do dad was a lawyer mom
stayed stayed home with kids
um professional she was a
semi-professional Pianist so she used to
spend most of her days practicing piano
which was either really cool or really
annoying well you know it's funny yeah
it was I thought it was I thought it was
annoying but then I had friends come
over like man that's really nice
background and I recognize I do love
classical music I don't you know I don't
over index on it but I do have a love
for it and so uh so yeah it was it was
it was nice but yeah really nice
childhood twin brother older sister
younger brother and was there any
military in your family no none
um my dad was a Private Pilot so he'd go
flying on the weekends and uh so he'd
take us all up and my twin brother and I
got hooked from the from the beginning
um you know he put us in the in the in
this in the right seat and we'd help
help him steer the aircraft and so my
favorite my two favorite books growing
up were Chuck Yeager's autobiography
Jaeger and the right stuff and I read
those books I mean
a dozen times and all I wanted to do was
be a fighter pilot and I did well World
War World War II fighter pilot that's
all but um but we had this bent on
joining uh well first Air Force then we
found out that the Navy guys land on
ships are like well that's really cool
right so so then it was Navy uh all the
way this was pretty Top Gun then Top Gun
just made it made it even worse yeah
there's a wild thing uh one of my
buddies Dave Burke good deal Dave yes
they have this thing where
they call it getting aboard and and
basically there's some people that can't
do that that last thing which is land
The Boat Land the plane on the boat and
he had this one buddy that decided to go
in the Marine Corps instead of going the
Air Force and he made it all the way
through training was an F-18 pilot and
the last thing that he needed to do was
get aboard yeah couldn't get a board and
so if he would have been in an F-15
pilot in the Air Force or an f-17 pilot
he would have been good to go but he
couldn't get aboard it's just like that
last little thing I remember reading an
article Navy pilot of course I was
absorbing as much as I could back then
and then Navy pilot was quoted as saying
imagine uh putting a poached posted
stamp in the middle of a of a large rug
turning out the lights and then jumping
and landing on that posture stamp with
your tongue
that's pretty good yeah okay uh what
sport you said you didn't row what
sports did you play
um I I tried everything when I was a kid
back then you could he didn't have to
start a they did they didn't they didn't
put like a baseball glove in your hand
it's the only sport for you right you're
gonna be a champ and I mean depending on
where you grow up nowadays you have to
start if you don't start early you're
not going to make the high school team
right so anyway I tried everything
growing up uh when I when I got to high
school I decided I loved ice hockey but
I couldn't skate well enough to make the
team so I decided to play lacrosse I
felt like it was kind of a land version
of ice hockey and so I I walked on the
team freshman year never having played
uh played four years and was Captain by
the end of the by my senior year so
that's legit yeah it was that the only
sport you played I mean I did track I
did the track in the winter to get in
shape for lacrosse but uh that was yeah
that was about it and then when are you
thinking about the military so this is
high school are you thinking about the
military oh yes yeah they were bent on
Navy
um and so we were the kids and we were
the kids who had pictures of of jets you
know in our an audible our notebooks I
had it all over my room pictures of Tom
Cruise not so much Tom Cruise but uh but
yeah Jets and um yeah so it was yeah we
were known kind of those who knew us in
high school they knew that Divinity boys
wanted to on the military so and then so
then your plan was to obviously be a
pilot you have to be an officer so now
you know you got to go to college yeah
and where did you end up going to
college so went uh first year to an
aviation school down in Embry Riddle
down in Florida yeah my brother uh went
to fit down in Florida
um the plan was let's get our let's
start learning how to fly or maybe get
our pilot's license and go OCS uh but
after about a year there were half a
year there I realized well first of all
I realized getting you know
paying twenty thousand dollars a year to
get your pilot's license right it makes
sense so I I majored in avionics which I
wasn't good at at all
um my brother did get his license but we
also realized that the doors after the
Top Gun kind of surged the doors for
slots for OCS were closing so we're like
well we should probably find a an ROTC
unit and so we both applied to Purdue
and then transferred up to Purdue and um
I joined the ROTC unit earned a
scholarship there my brother did not but
he went um well after some years of kind
of figuring out what do you want to do
went to Marine PLC joined the Marines
and then flew harriers for three for 20
years yeah so at what point did you uh
realize you didn't want to be a pilot
it was never I didn't want to be a pilot
it was um I was after the first Gulf War
there was a Newsweek article I saw and
it was it basically had a guy's face on
it was camouflaged and said it was like
Special Special Operations forces right
and so I opened up this article and um
it was it was about seven pages and it
talked about all the spec ops units so
Army Navy Air Force Marines
through those seven pages there were
probably 20 25 pictures of guys you know
doing different things like underwater
in the snow skydiving desert jungle and
I recognize that out of that 25 pictures
like 20 of them were seals they were
just in different environments yeah and
I was like who are these guys right and
so I started I started reading about him
and um and then as I went to school I
still hadn't made a decision when I was
in ROTC But ultimately
I said to myself well I know I can be a
pilot but I don't want to I don't want
to wonder if I could be a seal and so
so I went that direction and
unfortunately got to build it and then
how did you I mean this is what so what
year is this this is not well graduated
in 96 so this might be 90s yeah
did you how hard was it to get a Billet
well it was difficult I mean there were
only they only my year they only
accepted 11
rotsy guys Nationwide
um and I think and it was like 16
Academy guys and so uh I was able to
link up with a guy in Connecticut who
was running he basically he had just
started a program where he just he was a
he was a retired Reserve seal uh Captain
Bisset and um and he had helped a couple
guys get through the you know get to the
get through the pipeline and so I linked
up with him he started you know helping
me with the physical test which I
ironically back then I I did I think I
did 11 pull-ups for mine for my test
which which I mean I wouldn't even have
you know gotten close to making it today
um but he also I think what he really
did was uh introduce me to some active
seals I drove down to DC to meet with uh
Captain down there got a recommendation
so I met with them they gave me
recommendations and then he helped me
put together a package which I then gave
to my ROTC unit because they didn't
really know how to do the seal thing in
fact you know during our summer cruises
there's there was something called mini
Buds and um I remember you know being at
my union going to my my unit officer and
saying hey can I go to mini buds he's
like oh uh all right let me look into
that and so a couple days later I think
oh you know there's no more billets for
mini Buds and I was like oh okay check
and so I went on a normal Navy cruise in
fact I went on a ship out here in San
Diego
um and one day throw on my whites and
just walked into the buds quarter I
could say hey can you show me around
um but ironically I get to buds I
realize that actually there were billets
there were extra billets for ROTC that
that he didn't know about so extra extra
Academy guys got got to go that year so
I never got too many buds but so this
was like 1996 you say
I remember there was a time period where
they were recruiting guys like the
officers were just kind of like off the
charts uh you know ivy league guys that
rode crew and were captain of the
football team and all this stuff and
then they kind of backed away from that
because they had these guys that were
basically there's there's several issues
that they were on into I'm sure we could
run into the attributes of what it was
but a lot of them were just they were
just there to do four years and get the
call and then get out and move on with
the rest of their life
um and other guys just didn't have any
Common Sense type thing and so they they
kind of opened up
I think they opened up their minds as to
who they were recruiting so it sounds
like you know you know we're laughing
you're saying you only did 11 Pull-Ups
and it's one of those things where you
know you look at a bunch of guys and
this guy can do 50 and this guy can do
42 and this guy can do 38 and this guy
and this guy can do 11.
well quite frankly being able to do
pull-ups is not
necessarily mean translate to any part
of being being an actual seal and being
a seal officer for sure right and so you
know obviously you must have some other
characteristics that they looked at and
thankfully they did because you know I
was also talking to uh a guy that worked
at buds a little while ago and and you
know he was basically talking about the
fact that
sometimes guys that are like for
instance bad Runners he's like yeah you
know I can't keep up with his boat and
he just gets run out of the boat and
that's it he's done
and he says and you and I both know and
we all know like being a good runner
does not necessarily make someone a good
seal no no you know it's fascinating I
think you can you you can agree with
this because you were actually in the
pre-war SEAL Teams longer than I was but
when I got to the SEAL Teams you know 97
or so uh you go I went to the SEAL Teams
and I recognized that all the quote Best
seals were or those who were considered
the best deals were all the best pters
they were the guys who came up you know
first on the runs and all that stuff and
PT was kind of the measure at the time
because we'd have these massive team pts
every day uh which was good from a
morale standpoint I think that's you
know that's something we lost in the war
but but what I recognized is when the
war started the all those guys started
to disappear I mean it didn't you know
the guys who were actually good at war
or good at the job that those
measurements left right and so so I
think you're absolutely right I think
the default
um tends to be physical because it's a
it's a measurable and you can see it um
but we all know those dark horses man
you know you gotta but there's you know
this is why we have a fire in the gut
Ward and buds right because you know I
don't think they have anything anymore
oh really yep okay that's oddly enough
it is odd yeah yeah I don't have it
anymore yeah uh yeah you know when I got
to the team so I went to oh I got to
team one and I would say there was a
little bit of uh
there was a little bit of a of a line
between like people that were good at
running and and then there was people
that were considered to be like good
team guys
and those sometimes the good Runners
were also good team guys but sometimes
the team guys weren't great Runners and
it really boiled down to like how good
they were at doing the job of being in
the field and that's what counted and
although I think from like uh maybe
senior leadership would look and go this
guy's our best runner he must be a great
seal and yeah that certainly
know and laugh like that just not as two
non-runners here yeah we could testify
I've never been I've never been accused
of winning running race
when I first got the buds I was goon
squad and I was literally on the
weekends practicing my running you know
on the beach on the soft sand because I
really hadn't done it and slowly I got
up to the end at the edge of the pack or
the back and then into the middle and
you know but I was going to squatting a
lot
so were you so how prepared were you or
what information did you have going well
you know I mean books back then were you
know hard to find uh brave men dark
Waters uh you know or Kelly wrote a
couple there was one um called the
Commandos which was probably the most
recent it was kind of at the time the
most recent book and it kind of outlined
hell week so
so I had a sense of what was going on um
the be something special recruiting
video that's all you need right
um ultimately I think um I I can say I
wasn't prepared enough
um but you know when I got there I just
I reckon I say I just had to do what I
needed to do and um even the old course
I mean you know again on the weekends or
after work I was going to practice the
of course I was running on sands you
know just to get going because I said I
just have to have to do it so and uh
what I knew I could do I think one of
the things I recognize at buds fairly
quickly was that uh it actually wasn't
about the physical it was about just
keep going you know and um and you
almost come to this sense that hey
there's only so many push-ups that
someone can make me do until I can't do
any more and at that point they're gonna
make me get wet it's like okay so I'll
get wet you know and I'll be I know cool
off and I'll go do more push-ups right
so so you almost come to a recognition
that you're going to get to zero and
just do what you can
um at zero and I think that's that's
what that's what that's what they're
looking for they're looking for that
recognition and that almost that comfort
in the effect that's yeah I'll just keep
going even if it's slow I'll just keep
moving so I'm not gonna give up was
there anything that was uh especially
challenging for you
well running was probably the most
challenging
um especially Beach running yeah I would
say yeah the water stuff I always love
the water stuff
um so if there was anything so drown
proofing was pretty much my favorite
thing to do okay um because it was a
time that no one was screwing with you
yeah so so I remember they'd have dog
and ponies and you know you know as the
buds class they'd have they'd say hey we
need volunteers to do these dog
components I'd always volunteer for
drown proofing because it was the time
they'd leave me alone you know for 30
minutes I could just Bob in the in the
pool so and pool comp and everything you
were just good in the water would you
did you grow up swimming yeah I grew up
yeah I grew up in Connecticut right on
the Long Island Sound so I was always a
water rat so yeah everything water
related I was comfortable doing
um I had I had learned to scuba dive in
college just deliberately um and just
recognized I just loved I just I loved
being in the water underwater so pool
comp yeah I wasn't wasn't an issue for
me I mean um yeah obviously I had the
normal stress for it but I I was able to
get get done the first time yeah it's
weird if if you're lucky enough to have
that Comfort I mean some of the some
dudes are just petrified yes every water
Evolution and usually they don't make it
I mean yeah it's not a good way to roll
into it yeah you're petrified of drown
proofing petrified of life-saving
petrified if not time that's right just
having that hanging over your head all
the time well especially if you fail a
few times and then you have to do it uh
you have to wait the weekend and then do
it again but you know but you bring up a
good point because I think you know a
lot of people and you I'm sure you've
had this uh they've described seals as
fearless and I can't stand that
description because it's not none of us
are fearless you know because you know
courage requires fear and all of us have
little things that were like it we're we
don't like it you know they're they're
Team guys who love skydiving and they
hate diving there are Team guys like me
who love diving and I don't like
skydiving you know like climbing is
nothing it's not I would never climb on
my free time you know
um or bungee jump right
um but I think every single one of us we
learn how to move through it
um and so so you hope that every guy has
something they like about about the job
um but regardless of who you're talking
to that person had to move through some
fear yeah there's some stuff you're
gonna have to just suck up well and
here's another thing because because
um I've always you know and I got asked
by it was a while ago a bunch of sailors
they wanted to be seals and so I was on
a ship I did a one ship deployment as an
Illinois and they said Hey sir could you
just give us 30 minutes and talk to us
about being a seal so I said sure and I
got them all in a room there's about 10
of them and I started it by saying this
I said listen I want all of you to know
okay
when you're an Navy SEAL when you're
doing the job okay there's never any
cool music playing
um and there's no there's no like girls
on the side or beers it it always sucks
right they will the teams will take the
the fun out of everything if you're
diving it's cold it's dark it's dirty if
you're skydiving it's night time you're
waddling out of there nothing is ever
cool the coolest part is at the end when
you look back at what you did and you're
having a beer or whatever
um but you have to get that in your head
and I think I think buds
slams that into your head day one right
you come in with this mythology and
you're like oh cool and then suddenly
you're like holy crap what the hell is
this and so I think that's supporting
that whole premise is the fact that it's
in Coronado California that's right what
you're driving into if you ever get the
chance to go to San Diego you drive over
to Coronado as you drive over this
beautiful Bridge you look down in
Coronado it literally looks like a movie
depiction of of a little Heavenly
neighborhood yeah and it almost is with
a hotel says it almost is just this
beautiful place sunny beaches or a sun
style beautiful beach and somehow they
can take that well and make it well it's
people think southern California water
is warmer you know I actually went on a
run this morning I hit the beaches at my
West Coast ritual I always go down to
Coronado and take a run and so I hit the
beach at 5am I was like okay cool 5am
then we'll be on the beach right I get
there and immediately realize that it's
high tide right so I was like okay it's
cold because it's cold it's disclosed it
was 45 days yeah so so I start running
within the first hundred yards the waves
crash over my feet the sand is soft
right I'm just like I started laughing
because it was just beautifully
miserable right and um and I think
that's what you really start to you
start to relish that stuff so uh so hell
week you get done with that you get done
with pool comp
um get done with land Warfare so you get
done with buds
um yeah did you get rolled at all it got
rolled from the so I didn't technically
I I started with 209 I did their their
their in dock but before 209 classed up
officially they're like hey there are
too many officers in the class we're
rolling We're Gonna Roll the three
slowest Runners of course
so I got rolled to 210 so I never
classed up with 209 but uh so I so I
started with 200 210 and I graduated 210
yeah and then where where'd you go from
there what team did you go to sdv1 uh in
Hawaii but at the time
um classic budgeting you know we
graduated April 98 and uh there were no
there's apparently no no money to P PCS
officers and so like Hey we're gonna
keep you here and you'll do your STV
school because back then it was in San
Diego so we waited we lived you just
lived in apartments until summer that
year did sdv school went to jump school
and then I checked in January ninety
January 98 to sdv team one yeah and then
you get out there what did you want to
go to STV because you liked the water
did you actually put in for it well so
no my plan was to but when you go to
buds as you will testify everybody
especially back then everybody was like
don't do sdvs and so I got I got worried
about stvs so on my dream sheet I put
two all East Coast teams because I
wanted to go these guys and I got STD
one so yeah
um but I wasn't upset I was like okay
this is cool because I I did love diving
and I love that I love that aspect of it
and to be able to have done that I
thought was pretty froggy so and then
you get there
you get put into a platoon like um how's
that working yeah it was uh it was a
little bit we were a little bit delayed
there was a platoon that was already
formed up my one of my you know my best
friend is an admiral now he and I were
were kind of put in holding
got to do an exercise with one of the
students went out the Middle East did an
exercise and then platooned up a little
bit late
um but did one platoon and the
deployment
um out to the out to the Middle East you
know kind of went to the Middle East
quite a bit back then uh we're out there
and we were actually out there in in
Bahrain when the coal the USS Cole got
in so we actually did some response to
that
um so yeah I did one deployment as an
aoic
um there at scvs and then what was the
next stop Seal Team two okay so uh I was
I I'd always wanted to go to the east
coast and specifically Seal Team too
because all the books back then you know
were older books so they focused on one
still team one and still team two and so
you say you got to you just you and I
just missed each other too yeah because
I got I left there in 2000 the spring of
yeah the spring of 2000 and I checked in
January 2001. check yeah so and does
that work did you go straight to a
platoon Commander no yet again I was
delayed
um I did a I the only way I could get
Seal Team two you know interesting so my
my buddy and I we call the detail for
detailer from Hawaii and both of us want
to go east coast so he gets on the phone
first he's like I'd like to do an a I
like an OIC on the east coast and the
guy's like yeah I have one a teammate
he's like cool I'll take it
so he's like my buddy's here so I got on
the phone yeah I want to know I see on
the East Coast that was my last one
you missed it by a phone call you missed
it by a phone call yo um but he said uh
he said you know if you want you can do
an LNO you know back then uh they were
we were deploying guys on ships on both
carriers and marplatoons and they
usually put a seal officer as an lnl on
their ships
and so it says I said I said listen can
I go to Seal Team too she said he said
yeah you know you need to do an Eleanor
I said I'll do an Eleanor but I want to
do a carrier I don't want to do a bark
because I always loved Aviation I just
wanted he said deal so I went checked in
and then did a did my first deployment
with the John F Kennedy battle group as
at LNO on that carrier dude this is
crazy so uh my platoon at Seal Team 2
was the strike platoon we won on the USS
John F Kennedy there you go the last
conventional carrier there you go so
yeah it was actually turned out to be a
great deployment we I mean obviously 911
happened uh is that while you were on
deployment No in fact we it was before
we deployed we were actually getting
underway for comp2x uh on 911. so the
news heard the word comp2x in a long
time it just said shutters I know I know
these are the echo Charles these are Big
like Fleet exercises that you're doing
and the whole fleets out there all these
ships and you're gonna get tasked with
all these missions and it's just it's
just like a operation complication for
two weeks that's what I have that's
right yeah and and the Battleground
group got underway on the morning of
September 11th and so all the news all
the news reports said that there was a a
strike battle group that got underway
within hours of the attack which is
hilarious because that wouldn't it
wouldn't happen that way right it
happened to be within hours and so uh
and so we actually steamed right up to
the east coast off the east coast of
Virginia there I flew off and went to
the teams to check in to see what was
going on and uh you know get a sense of
everything so and then you guys did that
but then did you go on a normal
deployment yeah I still got back from
there uh platooned up as an OIC
um and started that work up and then of
course then Iraq was kicking off and so
because we were you know our pretended
pretty well in the in the training rco
sent us to Iraq and when was that what
year was
2004 yeah 2004.
yeah oh so I remember when you guys
showed up you guys did you guys go up
north did you go so we started up North
and then um and then came down south and
we took over the the security Mission uh
yeah we started it yeah so
yeah I had a very lucky career like I
got wrapped that up and went home and a
few months later you guys were doing the
uh the security yeah yeah and then so so
how was your work up when you were a
platoon Commander it was great it was it
was standard
um you know uh did the well obviously
the the you know the individual
trainings all the guys went to schools
then we did our our uh our platoon
training did all our our schools um and
back then it was all well as you
remember they had just
um implemented the the the
nsw 2000 Force 21 I think it was called
um brilliant idea we didn't know that it
was going to be so brilliant right
because it just set us up to deploy in
such a perfect way
um but they hadn't they hadn't changed
the the training program so we did all
the regular blocks you know you know
Mobility diving CQC all that stuff uh
and um and then went straight to when we
when we went out there we went straight
up to mosul and started there yeah yeah
so I remember that because we didn't see
you guys so you guys literally turned
over with us I was a team seven right
and you guys arrived in well I went home
sometime around April yeah but you guys
I think you guys might have showed up we
I might have high-fived a couple guys
that I knew from Team two yeah and then
you guys rolled straight up to mosul
right after that I think you guys had
people that stayed down in Baghdad as
well yep I think yeah we had some
Illinois guys who stayed down which was
also fortuitous based on the fact that
we all after you know after a few after
about a month and a half all went down
to Baghdad to start running that that
PSD did you guys chop under the Team One
CEO no uh or it was your team two CEO on
deployment too he was on the point with
us so and so what happened was the Team
One CEO stayed out west to continue
running direct action and our team 2co
ran the the PSD Mission got it yeah so
both CEOs were deployed got it okay yep
now I'm now I'm remembering and also the
I remember this too the MARSOC like debt
one the first one first Marine showed up
yep and that was cool too because a
bunch of those guys I had done when I
was in enlisted guy I did two
back-to-back article Tunes out here at
Team One wow and so we knew all these
Force Recon guys and a lot of those
Force Recon guys became the debt one guy
so we high-fived with those guys as well
and uh had the good times yeah so so
that deployment you do a little bit of
direct action and stuff up north yeah a
little bit of D.A up north only about a
month and a half and then um get drawn
down to PSD and um yeah that was a
deployment um and that was the focus for
the teams
um for
I think a year and a half before they
were able to pass that off yeah yeah
the mission was there was a bunch of
Iraqi leadership government leadership
that everyone in the country well a lot
of people in the country wanted to kill
yeah and they had to keep those those
individuals safe I mean from a strategic
level those guys had to stay alive and
so this was an incredibly important
Mission I mean it was the the highest
the most important mission in the in the
Iraq War at that time and was to keep
these was there seven of them right
seven yeah the PM the president a couple
others of uh and yeah and then yeah
seven with seven different details yeah
it was it's funny I was um on a call
about a month ago with uh we're all
retired now General George Casey and he
was out there in charge of the whole
effort and I was telling him hey I was
out there and he's like yeah I remember
you guys all you wanted to do all I kept
hearing was get us out of this Mission
get us out which made sense because you
know you know we can only do it for so
long and that wasn't our primary medal
so uh but again you know it's this idea
I think um
seals spec operation Special Operations
holistically are designed to do what you
have to do I mean you could adapt you
can you can mod you can you just hey
what's the job okay we'll do the job and
we might complain on [__] and moan but
um we'll still do the job well uh and
that's what we did yeah I've always
talked about the fact that um you know
and we're getting better now but when
you and I were in especially at that
time there was no Doctrine on anything
right and so you would know how to do a
direct action Mission because some other
guy had come back and taught you how to
do it the Vietnam guys taught us how to
do raids like it's all was word of mouth
and occasionally you get some
photocopied thing with some weird stick
figures on it about what your Patrol
formation could be but it was all it was
all like word of mouth and then you'd go
out and you'd do it and you'd adapt and
you'd figure it out and so we didn't
have any Doctrine which can be a
negative right if you've got some kind
of a mission that you probably should
have some baseline to do and yet you
can't pull out a book whereas like the
Army can pull out what is it if uh FM 7
tack 8.3 Bluetooth Squad there it is
right here's everyone's job here's how
you actually get the mission here's
where's people's fields of fire is it's
all laid out for you which is awesome
yeah
the the issue is when you have something
like PSD you know security for a bunch
of of high value people
and there's no there was no book on that
no there was no Doctrine no one had any
Doctrine on that well the only Doctrine
we again the only thing we drew upon was
that uh our our specialized unit had
been doing it
um up in the in Europe for a few years
and we had some guys who were from that
command who were like oh we know how to
do this we know we we've done it before
and that's why we were tapped to start
doing because those guys started
training all of us and and they they
were familiar so so yeah you're right I
mean the doctor I think I think officers
and I think they do a little bit more of
this but it would you know officers who
could
come in with a better understanding of
just field maneuver and and and
Battlefield stuff right is advantageous
but at the same time this disability
kind of come in almost with a with an
infant's mind is is something we do
pretty well yeah it takes a certain
level of
of
open-mindedness to go oh here's the
biggest Strategic Mission that you've
got in the country cool yeah we got it
yeah we'll do it and and to pull it off
I mean think about that all the
thousands and thousands of movements of
individual movements of these
individuals over a year and a half into
hostile territory where there's so many
people trying to kill them and then and
they all made it you know they all lived
and that's uh pretty amazing pretty
amazing
job for all the boys and and like you
said
seals don't want to be on defense right
and that the the Crux of that job is
you're you're on defense you're on
defense although when people don't
understand is the offensive nature of
that job I mean there's so much
preparation and planning uh and I think
I think one of the reasons why
the guys did it so well is because we
just look at environments differently
we're always hedging our our our our
situation to the best of our ability
we're comfortable with uncertainty but
we'll get it to whatever percentage we
can in terms of looking ahead and
certainty before we say okay that's
that's the line we got to be good here
um and so I for me it was a real
education on the
on the on the offensive nature of that
of that type of mission of course when
you're in the moment you're on defense
but you've you've offensively prepared
the environment so that you are hedging
your bets in your in your advantage
which is pretty cool yeah the the shift
of the mindset from this is a defensive
Mission how do we make it how can we be
offensive as we possibly can and I
remember we we actually we did when I
was at Team two yeah we did training for
this we actually did like some scenarios
where oh you got to protect this guy and
I remember uh you know having
conversations with guys that had worked
with other units
and their what they were taught wasn't
they told us this or like hey what when
we worked with these other units that do
this for a living
here's what they would say oh you
collapse on the on the person that
you're trying to protect you it's a very
defensive mindset
and he's like what we would do is oh
there's a threat we would attack the
threat you know it's like it's like the
opposite mindset and he said you know
what when they would play it out you
know with simunition or whatever the
people that would go on offense and
attack the threat would do better than
the people that were just trying to
surround the principle and get him out
of there right you you do want to do
that but if you've got guys that are
attacking the attacker it ends up being
a better move yeah you get into their
their loop I mean you get it you know as
soon as someone if they're if if an
enemy is in attack mode and suddenly
they find that someone is getting into
their space it puts them on the
defensive and so I think that's a really
cool mindset and strategy that uh that
that you know we applied yeah yeah so
you get done with that deployment and
what what's next so then I screen for uh
the maritime component the specialized
unit uh for uh for the joint Special
Operations Command the maritime
component uh screened and got got
accepted and went to that selection and
how was that selection for you
I and I enjoyed it I mean I I um it's
about nine months I enjoyed uh so I
would I would describe that whereas buds
the primary responsibilities to not quit
the uh there there's a performance I
mean there you have to you have to be
able to perform
in in the in what they're asking you to
do
um but I just like I love the I love the
um
the Precision so I grew so growing up
you know I I said my mom classical piano
my dad John Denver I love all of it but
I started getting into metal and um and
and it was probably in the in the late
80s I heard uh master puppets for the
first time and um and I was I was like I
had been listening to like you know uh
Motley Crew and things like that and I
was like I just want something heavier
there's something there's got to be
there's got to be more and I um and I
heard master puppets and and justice for
all I heard those guys and I realized uh
well I guess I realized this later in
kind of this mental autopsy that um I
loved the what I call Precision violence
uh Precision aggression and the way
these guys played and I love thrash
metal but I mean with the palm muting
and the fact that you could hear every
single chug on that E chord and it was
just so fast and so precise and that's
what I felt like when I was doing this
kind of Hostage Rescue level CQC it was
just so fast and so precise and so I
just realized I love it um and musically
I love it I mean the the rappers do it
you know who rap fast and precise I love
if it's a country if it's a banjo
playing fast and precise I love it I
mean I just anything fast and precise
kind of violent you know Precision
aggression I love and um I love the
challenge it was you know I enjoyed it I
met Metallica just like in passing and I
and I walked up to uh James Hatfield and
I told him this story which was that
when I got to Seal Team One in 1991
there was a big stereo system in the
weight room and it was had the old
school five disc CD changes yeah and it
was all the Metallica albums were in
there and it was locked shut it was the
only thing I could listen to perfect and
it was like yes perfect I knew that's
when I had made a good decision by
Jordan the name yeah right yeah that's
yeah that's awesome yeah they that so so
my so the training reminded me a little
bit of that uh just this this very
precise aggression
um which I love because I thought seals
were always that way and obviously
underwater it's a little bit different
but I thought we were just designed
differently in the sense that yes we
we deliver violence but we do it every
single time you move every single time
your trigger finger moves it's with a
thought it's it's thought through and I
um and I really enjoy that that level so
so then you get done with that with the
training yeah and now it's time you're
you're get put into a squadron you start
going on deployment yeah and and what
are those what are the how many of those
how what's your what's your op Tempo
like yeah back then it was um it was a
nine month cycle three months uh three
months training three months of what's
called alert and then three months
deployed
um and then rinse and repeat
um but because the war had started
it was basically uh you know it well I
guess prior to the war it was it would
be basically six months of training
three months alert and then it became
three months training three months alert
three months deployed and um and so the
training Cycles got got crunched uh and
it was just very fast uh and and
tough tough but cool because the op
Tempo when you were there was so intense
uh but uh but yeah I did I ended up
doing
um two deployments as a true I did a
toilet as a I was kind of the Apso for
the Squadron and I had two deployments
as a troop Commander there were those
were those Iraq or Afghanistan well two
uh two Iraq one Afghanistan yeah and
then what what time frame were these
this was uh 05 through 08. yeah oh five
million yeah so you and I may have
crossed over I'm sure we did I I'm you
know in trying to think through I mean
we may have crossed paths here because I
even when I was running training I came
out here I we probably sat down in some
of the same training conferences to talk
about stuff right but uh yeah you never
know yeah yeah so so you're out on those
deployments how's that how's that from a
leadership perspective
it's um
I mean you're learning the whole time
and I think uh I think you try to when
you in any in any seal platoon
um
especially as a new officer you go in
there and if you're not willing to just
listen first you're you're going to be
screwed right especially when you have
guys who've just been there done that uh
and so so to go in and listen first and
watch and and hear the expertise and it
was almost like getting into a machine
that was already moving and you just try
to say okay how can I help this move
better and faster and so it was a
tremendous
lesson in leadership for me because
that's when I recognize that you have to
you have to be a part of the machine
it's not necessary I mean the I think I
always say kind of
leadership is not a position it's a
behavior right and and I talk about this
concept uh called Dynamic subordination
which is really decentralized leadership
and I you know and the story of this
kind of me thinking about this comes
after I left the teams I was talking to
a bunch of Executives and they asked me
I had a flip chart next to me and they
said hey Rich can you draw the task
organization with the task organization
looks like for a for a high performance
team
and so I was stumped when they asked me
that because I had the models in my head
but I was like this these models don't
apply I had the pyramid model of course
I was like well that doesn't apply
because you know that's too slow and
bureaucratic the flat model which was a
mild Rebellion to the pyramid and I said
um that doesn't apply because you know
in a flat model first of all it's hard
to know who's in charge and second of
all it because it's flat something can
happen on the right side line that
doesn't it's not seen or heard by the
left sound line so it gets silent
information can get silent on a high
performing team information never gets
Silo so flat model is out and then I had
the Robert Greenleaf servant Leadership
Model where the leader is the upside
down pyramid leader sits on the bottom
and I always tell people I was like if
you're gonna if you're gonna land on any
one of those philosophically that's the
one you can land on it's a good one
however it's still not a high performing
team operates because in a high
performing team a burden is distributed
it's not all in one so so really in
frustration I basically drew a blob on
the board on amoeba and I said to the
group I said where do you think the
leader sits in this blob
and I got answers like you know front
back top bottom center I said you're all
of you are correct the leader is
wherever the linear needs to be in the
moment and and this is what I call
Dynamic subordination which is literally
this idea that a team understands that
issues and challenges and problems can
come from any angle at any moment and
when one does the person who's closest
to that problem and the most capable
immediately steps up and takes lead and
everybody follows and then it swaps it's
also alcohol Alpha swapping that alpha
position swaps and so I know you and I
as officers we're pretty much in charge
of every op we were on but didn't mean
we were always being supported in fact
it was usually the opposite we were
supporting other people and sometimes
the environment would shift and they'd
have to support us right but
but it was really uh and this really hit
me when I was actually in training and I
was watching close quarter combat
training because in close quarter combat
you'll see a group of four guys outside
a door and they'll go you know number
one man number two man number three man
number four they'll go in that room
that's suddenly clear that everything's
all clear well the next threat might be
close to the number four man so guess
what number four man becomes number one
man and so you see this and so no CQC
run is ever the same you know and it's
just this this just amazingly beautiful
violently beautiful dance uh between
leadership positions and I think that's
what I recognized the most and and fell
into quite
quite you know
quite well because that's kind of how I
liked leading but you know funny story
um
first deployment as the true Commander
I'm in Afghanistan
and uh we get this we get this it's our
first mission it's and it seems fairly
fairly good the compound's not too far
away easy drive there
relatively easy so we get this thing
planned out and um and as we're planning
we're you know we're getting little
things like uh you know we're gonna
change the crypto or this thing didn't
line up hey the gear we need is not
there so these little things little
ticks and um and I'm you know just
little enough you just brush them aside
right
but they're adding up and I'm I'm kind
of keeping it count in my head and so we
start rolling out and and now we're
driving and the first route fouled right
so we have to go second route that's
fouled and now we're like okay wait a
second you know okay we could probably
get this third route we get the third
route okay finally park now we're a
little bit late timeline's a little bit
skewed walking towards the target
finally we're walking towards the Target
and we start hearing whistling
and we just read a couple days before
some Intel on a unit that had been
ambushed and they had heard whistling
so I stop everybody I call my troop
Chief I'm like hey uh
I'm not feeling good about this one you
know I I've got there's too many ticks
and fortunately he was a great guy he's
like I agree and so I always joke on on
my very first op at that command as
troop Commander I called the CEO
who was a ranger back at the the base
that said hey we're turning around we're
we're quitting the mission you know and
I actually wrote A Blog on this is it's
it's okay to quit but but just never
give up right because because if you're
seeing this situation and you're not
paying attention and I realized it was
really it was really good for me to
understand that that's my job as the
leader I mean because so many guys who
do so many phenomenal things if I'm not
keeping abreast of all this stuff and of
course there were some guys who were
pissed and you know you have to you have
to take that that hit too but but that's
my job and it really taught me I think
in the hundreds of missions I did I
turned around on three and everyone felt
like I was quitting and everyone was
hard and on everyone we had guys who
were pissed off and upset but but I
recognize that that's that's the job you
know yeah I used to have the um used to
joke about it so when I was a platoon
Commander when I was a troop Commander I
called it Go Go criteria because you
know in the SEAL Teams they have no go
criteria if you don't have this many
vehicles it's a no-go if you don't have
this air support it's a no-go if you
don't have comms with this people to
know go so we have all these no-go
criteria so my joke would always be it's
for me it's go go criteria we're [__]
going right and but the but the
interesting thing was there was same
thing like there'd be a mission where
it's like hey we're going okay cool
hey we uh we actually just lost the air
cover for this part of the insert okay
we're going
hey it looks like the uh Army that was
going to support us with their vehicles
for qrf for the first half an hour
they're not going to be on station for
an additional three hours
okay we're going
hey uh the
whatever
Eleanor for that unit that was supposed
to be here for the brief he actually
didn't show up
you know what we're not going yeah so So
eventually you got to make that call of
hey you know what for me it was just the
the universe trying to tell me that this
was not a good op well and you and I
we've read these after action reports of
these these tragedies that happen and
these tragedies never happen with one
big thing it's always a series of little
things and so hindsight's always 20 20.
and I think if we're not as Leaders
understanding that we're looking for
those number of texts and no one knows
how many ticks it takes you can't say
well it's 10 ticks right no it's just
it's what the tick is and how does it
affect the mission and then eventually
what's your what's your no-go versus go
go you know and I think that's a that's
one of the jobs yeah the uh the other as
far as the leadership goes you know I've
had this conversation with so many
civilian companies and one of the ways
that I would explain it to them is you
know we are on an assault
and we go over the wall and there's a
guy that's in charge of opening the door
he's a breacher and guess what whatever
he tells me to do as the breach team
leader I'm gonna do it yeah I'm the
overall guy in charge out there I'm the
Ground Force Commander all these people
out there actually work for me and when
he says hey
step back 10 feet and go around that
corner I say Roger that that's right
when the point man says hey we're going
to shift to a different route I say cool
Roger that when my vehicle Commander
says hey I'm going to bump up and you
know and and get get up on this corner
here I say cool Roger that so you're
constantly people are going to lead what
they have control over and that's what I
actually want as I want everyone on my
team to be a leader and step up and make
things happen yeah so that's like it's
like a school of fish or a flock of I
mean we were literally amiibo we're not
we're not this this hierarchy or line
and that the position all the position
tells you is what your you know your
responsibility circle is you know for
for making [__] happen you know so uh
and I think that's important so yeah
yeah so your your do these deployments
and then at some point here you get uh
tasked with running the selection for
this jsoc group this Navy Json group
yeah not before I volunteered to go back
out to the teams I uh so one of my great
mentors you and I both know him um and
he was he was he's now retired but he
was my CEO at Seal Team two and then he
was also a deputy there he had been my
CDL schedule too and he had been at that
command and and I just loved him so much
and I saw what he get back and I didn't
I wanted to make sure I I stayed in both
communities kind of or both both I
volunteered to go to Seal Team 10 as uh
Ops XO and you know the other the other
component was my wife was uh this one he
was a group Commander he would well no
when I did it he was the deputy
Commander uh before he took group
um uh but we're tracking on the yeah
yeah
um but my wife was also sick of sick of
the command someday I'll have him on
here we have we've got some good stories
oh my goodness yeah he's yeah what a
phenomenal guy
um but my wife was also sick of the
command and she basically uh back then
um I mean they wouldn't even let wives
near the compound I mean she you know
she had to drop me off at the at the
fence and walk in and so she just she
was pretty pissed off and she sat me
down she's like listen you know I don't
think you I don't think I can take you
staying there um and that's a pretty big
um thing because because you know
typically especially as an officer if
you leave
chances you're coming back are you know
you know you don't know you know it's a
it's a Gamble and so but I you know how
long have you been married for at this
point we got married in 01 so this was
uh this was now 08. we got married when
you were when you got to team two
basically yeah so I met her in Hawaii
though and um and then I got to team two
she moved she was she's from
Pennsylvania but she moved from Hawaii
back to your Virginia Beach and so and
we had two kids by then um so she's
already pissed bro you took her oh my
gosh
so so I tell the story is funny um it
was it was probably 07. um and I was um
yeah 07. and I came back from one of my
deployments and it was very successful
deployment and you know and my wife's
pretty sick and tired of hearing how
awesome her Navy SEAL has been she's at
home with our one-year-old and our
three-year-old and it's a couple days
I've been home and I'm just a freaking
loser total loser total loser and I come
home and so I'm at home I'm doing some
projects and I hear her from the back of
the house she's like hey Rich can you
grab that she's in doing something with
the kids can you grab the Q-tips now
admittedly and embarrassingly
I didn't want to drop what I'm doing
because I'm just like I don't know where
they are
and and instead she's like no they're in
the bathrooms like okay I better drop
what I'm doing so I kind of begrudgingly
drop what I'm doing I go to the bathroom
I step in the bathroom they're not here
and she's like they're in the closet I
open the closet door they're not here
she's like they're right there on the
Shelf in the closet I'm like I'm telling
you they're not here so now I hear her
footsteps I was like okay I'm gonna
prove her right right her arm comes from
over my shoulder grabs the Q-tips puts
him in front of my face and says they
are right here and As She's Walking Away
she's like it's no wonder you guys
haven't found Bin Laden
she's like she's like you guys are
probably going these caves he's just
sitting there you have male eyes you're
not seeing anything which ironic I say
ironically it was a female I mean it's a
team but a female who found found him
right so he just went and got him the
wives seal wives are badass they really
are I know you could testify that yeah
but yeah so it was uh it was 08
volunteer to go back out to team 10 was
did an Ops Ops then EXO deployed with
them uh so that was about a two-year
tour and then and how did you like that
I loved it yeah I loved it loved the CEO
loved the master chief loved the team
um
again you're back on you know six month
deployments which are rougher um but uh
but I was I recognized uh
I recognize the the the the healthy
nature of seeing both sides and staying
connected and
um
and uh and of course it helped you know
at the home it helped on the home front
um
uh but then was asked to go back to to
run training and you know my at that
point they changed the command you know
there was there was issues the command
had started to and actually nsw
holistically had started to do a lot
more for the families and the wives
bring the families in they said which
there's a great concept right and so
so it was it was a better it was a
better situation and I was happy to go
back and and went back in um
uh early 2010 and and took over
selection yeah so this point when um you
take over selection this is kind of the
kind of the beginning of this book that
you end up writing yeah and uh with that
it's probably a good time to just jump
into some sections of this book
um
well I'll just jump into it right here
here we go
you say this I learned about attributes
the hard way on the job and under
pressure from the top in 2010 I was in
charge of training for one of the
Premier Special Operations units on the
planet our Command selected candidates
from other spec ops teams men who
already proven themselves to be
exceptionally skilled and committed one
Friday afternoon I was sitting across a
small table from one of those men still
sweating his fatigues from a long day of
training he was a Navy SEAL with eight
years of experience behind him a
seasoned Warrior who'd completed dozens
of missions his record was saturated
with glowing reviews and recommendations
from his superiors he was also
recognized as a mentor to younger less
experienced guys and he'd been promoted
at every available opportunity often
early so you're sitting across the table
from the stud on paper he was perfect
but three weeks into a nine month
training program we already knew he
wasn't going to make it the selection
and training class had just finished a
week of Close Quarters combat exercises
or CQC you've seen it in the movies and
on TV a SWAT team or a squad of soldiers
busting into a building staring down the
barrels of weapons they're waving around
one of them shouting clear every few
seconds the Hollywood version is much
noisier and sloppier than reality though
in real life CQC is a complex sequence
of movements the exact order and timing
of which have to be improvised in a
fluid high stress environment where
mistakes can be fatal the lead man
focuses only on the door and waits for
the signal squeeze or a word from the
second man then he goes through the door
and turns left to right sweeping his
sight lying down the wall 90 degrees
toward the center of the room the second
man goes the opposite direction left to
the lead man's right or vice versa and
does the same visual sweep the third and
fourth men keep alternating directions
each of them scanning the room for any
bad guys who need to be neutralized or
good guys who don't all that happens in
a few heartbeats the guy sitting across
from me had in his career cleared more
rooms than he could likely remember but
each Special Operation team had its own
habits and techniques and we needed him
to learn our particular ones the
candidate at the table had started
strong but after the first week or so
things began to get a little shaky
little mistakes morphed into bigger ones
and his confidence was taking a hit he
knew he was falling behind and he tried
to like hell to catch up he stayed late
walking through scenarios practicing
techniques asking instructors for
feedback none of it was working one of
the most highly trained Warriors in this
world a man specifically recruited for
this specialized unit just couldn't keep
up
what was I supposed to tell him
that that at least he wasn't the only
one that more than half of the other
candidates washed out to that wouldn't
do no matter how gently words came out
you're not good enough is a hard blow to
anyone's ego let alone a guy of his
caliber and then there were my superiors
there's a high attrition rate for Canada
to want to get into Special Operations
units in the first place and that is by
Design about 85 percent of prospective
candidates for instance don't complete
basic Seal training but we were
recruiting men who'd already proven
themselves to be among the very best
special operators when only about 50
percent of those guys made it through
our training commanders farther up the
chain understandably wanted to know why
on that day in 2010 I didn't have any
satisfying answers
I told this highly experienced highly
decorated and highly competent seal the
only thing I could I'm sorry you just
didn't cut it
he wasn't happy either
so that's sort of uh you figuring out
why is this happening what can I do
better here
um yeah rough rough and and disingenuous
especially as a I mean you know the
leadership was obviously
needing some answers and wanting some
answers but as Cadre I mean you just
that we could do so much better um and I
think the collateral effect of that was
that these guys were leaving these guys
would even go back to their the regular
to their teams and they didn't feel good
and they were they were they hated where
they just came from and so so we were we
were looking at
um
a a real problem in the community of of
uh of hurt feelings and I say and I say
that I mean I don't mean that uh well
like animosity yeah yeah and so
so yeah my leadership said hey Rich uh
take a better look at this what's going
on and so I really had to start
deconstructing performance yeah as you
do this um you say you say here in the
book and obviously get the book it's
called the attributes I'm reading little
chunks of it
um you say this to begin figuring out a
better way to explain why so many
seemingly well-qualified candidates
weren't cutting it I decided I needed to
examine Our Roots so I went back to the
beginning 1943 and here you talk about
World War II you talk about Draper
Kaufman uh you know the the NCD use you
you go through some of that history and
have you read uh by by water beneath the
walls yes outstanding outstanding Ben
what up Ben Mulligan go get Ben
Mulligan's book yeah trying to give him
a shout out every time yeah awesome uh
just an incredible job he did on that
book
um so you start looking at that you say
your Kaufman understood though that
being a strong swimmer who could sneak
across the beach wasn't enough for his
recruits he needed men who could think
on their feet men who could adapt adapt
and flex as fast as the environment did
men who have the ability to be aware of
multiple aspects of their surroundings
could work together as a team and learn
things quickly and do so while under
unfathomable stress Kaufman realized in
other words that he wasn't looking for
recruits who knew how to do the job but
rather men who could do the job the
difference in that single word between
how and could is enormous the required
skills diving cartography Demolition and
so on could always be taught what
Kaufman needed were men with certain
innate attributes traits that are hard
wires hardwired into each person's core
so there you go
that's where you started looking at so I
thought about at the time you know now
it's 2010 I had already been on hundreds
of combat missions and I thought about
my own blood's experience and you know
in buds we
spend hundreds of hours running around
big hook boats in our head and 100
rounds running with 300 pound telephone
poles and exercising with those and
freezing the surf zone and I thought
about the hundreds of missions I'd been
on never on one of those missions or
thousands of training Evolutions never
on one did I carry a big handy photo or
a telephone pole right so what they were
doing to us was not training Us in the
skills of the skills and so that's where
I started to distinguish this this
difference between skills and attributes
yeah
um I did do one op one time
I did enough I did a training up and off
the coast of North Carolina we came
across the intercostal waterways we
ended up it was low tide everything was
a disaster we're in this mud flat we had
to carry our freaking zodiac in a mud
flat for like a long long ass time did
you put on your head no we didn't put it
on our head though we did a low carrier
we did a low carry yeah yeah
um
so you say this skills and attributes
get conflated all the time yet they're
inherently different different things
right yeah
um
and and again you've got a whole section
on this skills are learned these are
some of the high points skills are
learned skills direct Behavior right uh
explain direct Behavior so so skills
tell us what to do in in known specific
environment so here's how I'm going to
ride a bike or throw a ball or shoot
again there's a Target here's the skill
here's what you do here's what yeah
here's what here's here's when to write
here's what to do here's where to write
right and and then finally because
they're they're visible they're very
easy to assess measure and test you can
see how well anybody does any one of
those things and you can put scores in
stats around this is what we go into
organizations and hiring it's like you
can put them on a resume and this is why
we get seduced by skills when we're
hiring right but they don't tell us how
we're going to show up in stress
Challenge and uncertainty because in an
unknown environment it's very difficult
if not impossible to apply a known skill
and so that's when we lean on the
attributes the attributes are innate
right we're all of us are born with
levels of patience or situational
awareness or adaptability now you can
certainly develop those things over time
and experience but you can see levels of
the stuff in very small children which
means there's a nature nurture element
and then attributes inform our Behavior
they don't direct it so in other words
my son's levels of perseverance and
resilience informed the way he showed up
when he was learning how to ride a bike
and he was falling off a dozen times
doing so and then finally because
they're hard to see they're difficult to
measure and test you can't it's hard to
test someone's levels of patience or
whatever and so they're the most visible
and visceral during stress challenge
uncertainty which is what made our
laboratory my laboratory where there's a
specialized command or even Buzz the
perfect laboratory for seeing the stuff
I mean buds really ultimately is an
attribute selection course that's what
it is you learn some skills certainly
But ultimately that's questionable if
that's questionable really sqt is where
you learn you really and then you go to
your team and you start really learning
but it's an attribute selection course
and so uh and so these attributes these
inherent qualities are really what Drive
the the distinction as to whether or not
we can operate in these environments you
know here's a funny story I'm not sure
if you heard this one because I heard it
when I first got the buds because it
obviously happened sometime before me
maybe even way before us but the story
goes and back then the story goes this
kid shows up and he wants to be a seal
and they basically say well you to swim
you know 50 meters he's like okay so you
take this kid to the pool and it's going
to be 25 meters one way and 25 meter
back and um the kid jumps in the pool
and sinks right to the bottom and starts
walking across the bottom of the pool to
one end and then walks across the bottom
pull back the other and he comes up and
he's gasping for air nearly drowning and
his structure looks at him and says what
the hell are you doing and the kid who's
still casting his breath looks at the
instructions I'm sorry instructor I
don't know how to swim and the
instructor pauses for a second looks the
kid says that's okay we can teach you
how to swim right yeah and it's because
the instructor knew if this kid had the
attributes the balls because that's one
I guess that could be natural right but
to show up to Navy SEAL training not
knowing how to swim teaching him to swim
the skill was going to be the easy part
right and so so the idea is and you know
we go into business obviously I don't
you know some skills are necessary just
for basic entry right
but if you want teams if you want the
highest performing teams on the planet
which are teams that not only do Well
when things are going well they do well
and things are not going well you have
to look at attributes and so I in the
book I talk about this dream team
Paradox where you you hear it all the
time these teams are put together best
graphics designer best marketer best
lawyer whatever best best and then they
slowly turn you know and they go they go
well when things are going well right
but as soon as the environment changes
as soon as things go go sideways the
team turns toxic and if you don't if you
haven't built your team on the
attributes you're not going to have a
team that that survives yeah uh
I'm questioning if I should tell this
story but I'm going to but I've told you
I think I've told before so my uh my
daughter was having her birthday down at
the beach and um
I ended up taking all of her friends and
like organizing them into teams and
having them compete against each other
and this was at uh San lejo State Beach
as a matter of fact and there's a river
up there and so I was having to do these
contests you gotta you know drag this
log because there's all kinds of fun
stuff to drag this log and who can do it
faster who could build the tallest you
know sand
Tower in five minutes ready go and the
cool one of the cool thing was that as
I'm watching them I'm like I see like
one person that steps up and starts
leading I see someone that doesn't care
I see someone that's lagging I see
someone that will do whatever they're
told to do as soon as they're told do it
I was like this is the freaking little
sea level platoon of eight-year-old
girls right this is crazy like it's the
same exact humans yeah but then the
funny part is my daughter I said okay
you guys go across the river whoever can
bring the biggest rock back wins and so
my my daughter she's swims across the
river also in across the room and
everyone's grabbing you know
rocks that are the size of a baseball
maybe the size of a grapefruit my
daughter uh this is my middle daughter
Rana she picks up like a legit rock that
is you know like a ball a small Boulder
and she starts back across and she
clearly she's not gonna be able to swim
with it and I'm watching I'm like well
this is going to be interesting and she
just like like this kid that you're
talking about the pool she just goes and
her head just disappears and you know
five seconds go by six seconds go by
then her head pops up and she's she
barely gets her head mouth out of the
grabs of breath of air goes back down
keeps walking yeah comes back up and
grabs another breath of air cups walking
and then finally like her head Rises up
on the other side as it gets more
shallow she walks up and just drops the
thing at my feet known Victory and she
wasn't she didn't win that did she she
wasn't the first was she oh she freaking
one like heartbeat she was like you got
the biggest rock it was like known
Victory she dropped it like whatever
yeah I got this I was like okay yeah you
definitely want that one it's
um I mean this is this is where a lot of
teams hiring uh they get they get
confused they conflate these things and
they think someone with the with the
best skills is the best person and um
and this is why I think uh
you can pick certain environments where
just attributes show up more than skills
and uh and you know obviously Back Ops
is an environment like that this is
where I talk about like different sports
in in many sports skills take
predominance right but things like
fighting you know and I don't fight you
know just I know people who do and I you
know I look at it with interest but uh
but you can't predict necessarily what
the other person it's uncertainty so
there's actually there's adaptability
there's perseverance there's all these
things come into play climbing would be
the same thing and so so I think these
are this is where you start I'm really
if I'm obsessed with something with
anything I'm obsessed with who we are as
human beings at our most raw because
that's the real us right and um and we
always hear it you know it's when when
the [__] goes down the real us shows up
and I'm like okay who's that because we
had the we had the great gift
in our careers of understanding who that
person is and understanding who that
person and all the people around us and
and that allowed us to be the teams we
were I mean I know you you would agree I
mean I knew my guys I mean I could see a
silhouette and I knew that guy that's
how well we knew each other because we'd
seen we've lived each other at the most
raw and a lot of people don't get that
opportunity and you don't have to go
through Seal training to do it right
it's just understanding these these
qualities because because these
attributes when we fall back to like our
most Raw it's what these attributes are
wrote to running so we should know what
we're high on what we're low on so uh
uh as you start talking about uh
attributes here you say this uh but the
right stuff by Tom Wolf basically meant
things hardwired in the skills in the
skilled Pilots that allowed them to
function at the highest level no matter
how badly circumstances went sideways he
meant in these three words attributes
that's what the right stuff means
um and then it's the things you talked
about they're Elemental they they inform
rather than direct what you're going to
do and
attributes are difficult to assess
measure and test and and that is the
truth and that's why you know like um
you don't know they don't know who's
gonna make it through SEAL training no
basic SEAL training they don't know
who's going to make it in despite and
listen there is a there is a an element
of
if this guy does great on his PST the
the physical standard test if he does
great on it it it does indicate that
this guy had the discipline to work out
he had the wherewithfall to stick to a
program so there it does indicate some
of their attributes sure but it's not
necessarily there's also people that are
just really good athletes and they like
to work out and therefore they show up
in great shape we every single seal has
a story of the guy in their class that
was you know uh Olympic this or a
whatever College athlete that and they
just quit yeah you know I think if you
and I went to Buds and um and this is
just a hypothesis there's there's no way
we'll be able to prove this but and we
could sit down with a class of of
candidates getting ready to start and we
could interview each one of those
candidates about
what their Journey was to get there in
the first place right I think that the
guys who had the longest journey the
toughest Journey we could say that guy's
probably gonna make it through you know
because I think that this is these are
the because it's they were executing
attributes to get there in the first
place I always say Bud selection starts
when you decide you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of there's a lot of
attrition that goes on because people
are like oh I wish I could do that but
then they stopped there right and so so
there's a journey whether you're
enlisted or officer to even get to the
beaches of buds and then it's then Bud
starts right and so so I think the the
folks and again you know there are
there's always exceptions but the the
folks who have
practiced these attributes and developed
the and of course we all have to come up
we have to we have to enter the game
with a little bit of a level right we
all have to have a level of
compartmentalization at day one of buds
or else we're not going to make it we'll
hyper develop it in buds but we have to
have it but there's we could I think
every single one of us could tell
stories from our past was like oh yeah
that was that was great right that was I
was compartmentally I mean I when I was
playing football in eighth grade my dad
didn't like he didn't want my mom
driving us around so he's like you have
to ride your bikes everywhere so my
brother and I would have to put on our
football gear and ride our bikes through
a town to get to football practice and
then practice and ride our bikes home
you know uphills all that stuff and I'll
build both ways both ways right but but
there's elements there that you know
you're just powering through and I think
we could you know there'd be there is
you know would never get it right but
you know I think we could we could pick
some of the guys yeah and we'd Miss some
of the guys we'd missed some of them too
yeah you know it's it's it really is
crazy the the demographics of people
that make it and don't make it yeah
there's it's like literally oh this rich
kid from wherever uh from Boston that
grew up you know with a silver spoon
oh he made it oh and this poor kid from
the ghetto that grew up you know without
a mom without a dad grew up raised by
his you know his grandma who didn't have
a job and lived off welfare he made it
and you can also say oh this rich kid
from Boston that went to a private
school and had a silver spoon he quit
yeah and this poor kid that grew up in
the ghetto quit yeah like it doesn't
make any sense it's one of the things I
love the most about that training and
one of the things I'm most grateful for
it's because
um I don't think there's a process on
the planet there are very few process on
the planet that allow you such a
zeroed out start yeah yeah I mean you
hit those I remember Lily getting there
and I felt relieved because it it took
so many people like I had to get in for
use and recommendations just to get a
Billet right and I remember getting
there I was like all right it's now it's
on me and I felt relieved because it was
now it was literally on me no one there
was going to force me out and um and we
we had this opportunity to zero out
everything and just start moving through
and it's just cool yeah Admiral McGuire
was telling me that
um he would tell when he was the CEO of
buds he would before hell week he'd say
if you guys don't make it through
because of you yeah like yeah like
pretty much we're not gonna drop you
look look people get dropped right but
vast majority of people right they quit
yeah very few performance drops yeah
yeah and those are out those are towards
the ends and it's all it comes in sqt
but very few and those are
am I correct in saying those are
attribute drops I would think so because
if you're talking about very base like
you know I remember we had a guy who got
who got dropped because he just he was
unsafe with his weapon while being safe
with your weapon has nothing to do with
the skill of hitting a Target it has to
do with the attributes of being safe
with your weapon right I mean it's a
it's a situation awareness it's
adaptability it's it's um it's all this
it's a I'm going to name off a bunch
right that's what he didn't have and so
uh and it's so Buzz just like this
training I was running and we used to
say I remember briefing Olsen and Olson
was Socom um I said sir this training
we're only it's nine months long okay
but but it's an attribute selection
course the whole nine months there are
attributes that we're assessing that's
that are going to take nine months to
see how can I see someone's level of
Integrity for example if I can't watch
them in a myriad of environments I can't
get feedback from their peers who tell
me how they are out in town you know
tell me what they do right who tell me
if they they just clean their their
stuff and leave right they don't help
out I have to so so some of these
attributes don't do take a little bit of
a long time to assess but I think the
the beauty of buds and then this process
is it is over a long period and so we
have all these we have time and we have
different environments inside of wish to
see these because they can be in some
cases contextual and even the ones that
we're naturally high on
sometimes we're just not sometimes we're
on an off day right and so so even just
one data point is not a decision point
you have to you have to see that across
across some time
um
going back to the book here you talk
about the uh kind of grouping these
things together you say that the ones
that follow are grouped into five
categories this is the attribute you're
actually going to talk about the book
grit mental acuity Drive Leadership and
team ability that does not mean that any
particular attribute is relevant in only
one context for instance empathy and
accountability are not reserved
exclusively for those in position of
leadership and open-mindedness certainly
is useful regardless of whether one is
especially driven rather the attributes
are organized on the page in a way
similar to how they tend to Cluster in
real life
people we think of as gritty for example
generally have healthy amounts of the
four attributes in that category but
again this is simply an organizing tool
it is entirely possible to have a
sizable amount of Courage yet not having
notable amount of grit and that's some
interesting Dynamic isn't it
um
so now we're going to get into this this
little site would you start talking
about the attributes themselves yeah um
I just kind of went through what the
major ones are and again the detail that
you give you give stories around all
these things uh examples you talk a lot
about the Neuroscience behind I know
you're friends with Andrew huberman
there's all kinds of great information
in the book so get the book um but to
hit some highlights
uh the the first section is the grit
attributes
and number one courage the ability to
manage fear in order to confront danger
difficulty or pain and you have this
this chapter is actually called Beware
of the fearless leader yeah that's a
very good you know if you've ever worked
for someone that doesn't seem like
they're scared of anything you should be
a little bit nervous so the officer
we've talked about but haven't named he
told me that he was the guy who said
Beware the fearless leader um he's gonna
get because he'll likely get you killed
he's the one that has the go go criteria
no no no yeah yeah uh courage is not an
absence of fear but rather the ability
to function despite being afraid this is
you on a C-130 at the middle of the
night at 20 000 feet getting ready to
jump off right uh fear comes 100 from
the brain this is you're talking about
Andrew huberman yep Andrew huberman
quote
it's a state of mind which is why people
are afraid of different things Heights
might not bother you at all but they
make others uncomfortable or maybe you
have a debilitating phobia of snakes or
rats both of which many people consider
delightful pets
that's not to say however that fear
stays in your head fear is considered by
neuroscientists to be the subjective
label that is put on the stress response
Andrew says and stresses more than just
a state of mind it's a physiological
response to our environment
but fear does start in your head it
begins with your brain detecting a
threat a process which happens in the
amygdala in very simple terms the
amygdala is a sort of tripwire for
sensing danger assessing both existence
and severity of a threat so that's
talking about what fear is
um
do you think you got used to overcoming
fear yes I think we all do yeah we all
do um and again it's this idea and so
there's a couple ways that when we start
talking about the physiology of fear and
the the the rise in our autonomic
arousal system when the things start you
know our breathing starts getting rapid
our vision starts to focus in
um we
were we all of us have well I think
we're wired first of all our courage our
courage circuits are wired so our
courage attributes are wired so we're
we're slightly above boiling point if I
would say boiling point is the average
or autonomic response trips I think most
seals are strip a little higher than
boiling point right which means we don't
it takes a little bit longer for us to
get that response but even when we do
get the response we also
I think unconsciously train ourselves to
manage our physiology in a way that that
keeps our frontal lobe online so what
happens as we as we approach amygdala
hijack or autonomic overload
um our frontal lobe is starting to take
it back a back seat our limbic brain our
lizard brain started to come forward
which when we reach full autonomical
overload we're acting without thinking
it's a lizard brain just survival so
this is this is advantageous for certain
things right when we touch a hot stove
we don't have to think about pulling our
hand away you know our brain takes over
pull our Android in most environments
however we want to think through
Challenge and stress right we want to
Think Through the environment I think
that's what we do we manage our
physiology we we keep our frontal lobe
back online and we're able to start
thinking through the process and so and
I know all of us have this and it's
funny you know again I'm in I've lived
in Virginia Beach now for you know 22
years
same house by the way and um I have a
seal who lives across the street from me
obviously was down the right side down
to the right and the seal who lives down
on the left I remember my wife saying
you know I'm so glad these these guys
are here because if something happened I
could go to them and they act like you
act and I'm like what do you mean she's
like well whenever something happens
they just calm down and they just start
working the problem and and this is what
we
practice doing so we don't we don't have
less fear we have just practiced the
process of moving through the fear every
time I jumped out of an airplane I felt
fear but I just knew the I knew and
understood the process of going through
that and part of that process is we
understand what to focus on in the
moment we don't overwhelm ourselves and
we basically and so I so I'm writing the
next book right now the next book is
called masters of uncertainty I'm going
to basically walk through this process
but but it's it's the idea where we say
okay out of all of this what do we focus
on in the moment how do we move our
Horizons you know we pick a horizon that
we move to and oftentimes we pick the
appropriate Horizon so that we can
actually move and it can be anything it
can be the next 10 seconds and serve in
Surf torture it might be 10 seconds you
know in hell week it might be I'm gonna
make the next I'm going to do the next
meal but we pick whatever that Horizon
is and so it's interesting I was having
lunch with a couple guys who I served
with and in the Squadron we of course we
did a ton of these hey hoes together and
we're talking about hey ho and we're
talking about like being on the ramp and
it's unknown DZ and you know for the
audience an unknown DZ is like basically
you look at a map and you're like oh
that looks like a good place to land and
you don't have any other you know Intel
I'm just like okay that's where we're
landing and you're hoping it's good so
it's there's there's some stress
involved and I remember he was and my
body was like yeah you know we're on the
ramp and I can remember it be unknown DZ
we have this Mission ahead of us all
that stuff and and there's only one
thing I'm thinking about just one I was
like what's that it's like nail the exit
you know that's the Horizon nail the
exit and then once you nail the exit the
next Horizon is okay pull my shoot okay
that's the next Horizon okay what's the
next rise get on heading right I mean so
and and we we are trained to think that
way and we do so in almost all
areas and elements of stress challenge
uncertainty that's what we do and that's
what combat is and we know that yeah no
I mean in uh the very first book that I
wrote about leadership was like uh
we call it prioritize and execute like
what's the biggest priority you've got
right now right that's what you need to
focus on and get that thing done yeah if
you try and focus on 14 different things
that are all going sideways at the same
time you're going to be a disaster
you're not gonna have the resources to
get it done you won't probably likely to
have the cognitive capacity to get it
done it's going to be a problem yeah
well and there's neurology right what
you're doing by doing that is you're
you're deliberately engaging your
conscious mind you're deliberately
bringing your conscious mind back in
your frontal lobe back online to focus
and make a decision move Focus make a
decision move so I love this so this
idea of I know Hebrew and I have talked
about this you know Ad nauseam but this
idea of we we have this we kind of have
this big so you talk about stepping back
which is which is exactly what happens
we step back we open our aperture we
start we say okay what about this
environment can I control in the moment
and then you pick something and you go
like this and you you focus in you do
that until completion then you go back
out again and you ask the question again
and one of the things I loved again CQC
was such a great
uh laboratory inside which because CQC
is this just extremely rapidly you're
going into a room with big focus and
you're focusing in you're shooting
you're going back out then you're
focusing you're shooting and it just
goes one after the other this is exactly
what we do in all environments and
anybody can do this and this could be
what I talk about and this is how we
become masters of uncertainty because
master of uncertainty is not oh I I know
all the environments no it's not about
training in two environments about
training the process by which you you
operate in an environment and that's how
you start moving through chaos
so did you go through the Navy Free Fall
school no I got unfortunately I got to
go well I don't know fortunately
unfortunate I went to Yuma okay so I
went through the old school Navy Free
Fall school after my first platoon
and it used to be the better you did the
less jumps you got and because you just
didn't have to repeat jumps so if you've
screwed it up you got to do it again you
screwed up again you got to do it again
and I did fine I think I screwed up one
jump and I had 19 jumps at free at Free
Fall School
and so I'm totally incompetent right
it's basically completely no just enough
to get yourself hurt yeah and so then
then I mean then I'm to jump back into a
workup and now I'm going through work up
we go to land we go to it so now it's
been
so I've done 19 jumps probably in
whatever two weeks and then I I don't
jump for I don't know how long it's a
long time long time don't jump like like
a year probably like a year no jumping
then then I get on a jump and
where like where there was a guy there
that was a very experienced jumper and
we're we're just doing a jump at the
command a team one we're doing a jump at
the command we happen to get a bird like
hey you guys wanna jump yeah well hell
yeah haven't jumped in freaking a year
you know I only have 19 jumps yeah I
want to jump
so we get on this bird and we go up
we're supposed to be jumping at whatever
12 500 feet normal jump you know
and there's there's uh a ceiling right
there's cloud cover
and and and so well we can't get up to
12-5 and so you know we're like okay
we're gonna go down low we're gonna take
it to whatever six still not coverage so
now I'm like okay so now we're down to
five we get down and finally and this
guy is a great guy he's like a a guy
from from the Special Operations Command
great dude you know he's a Master Chief
and
so he's like hey guys this is it like
we're there's there's just we got to get
down low we're going out it at whatever
it was we're going out at 2200 and uh
and I was like which just just let me
that's usually pull out yeah I mean it's
usually 4 000 is pull out so now you're
going and I was like I was like what and
you know we're friends you know he's a
master chief but like we're friends I'm
like what are we going on it's like
2200. he goes like 2200 just to hop and
pop and I was like he could and it was
actually not just me there were several
of us that were all in the same platoon
all had just gone through Free Fall
school year before all of a sudden
experience so so finally I go like
what's what do you mean hop and pop and
he's like hey go out get stable count to
two and just pull and you know he's like
yelling in the aircraft and he's you
know just got a smile on his face he's
trying to be cool and I was like Roger
that
because you've never done one of these
before and I was like negative and he
and he's like what about you guys
they're all like negative and he goes
hey don't worry guys you'll be fine
just don't Ziggy the exit is what he
said just don't send you the accident
which I'm thinking like I I mean I can
barely get out of a freaking aircraft at
this point yeah so and went out I didn't
dig the exit I'm still here still alive
but uh and and that's all you're
thinking yeah yeah nail the exit and
then you're worried about the two that's
that's what made me think of it was you
said the guy's thinking just like just
just get just get just don't Ziggy the
accident yeah she's pretty pretty good
instruction man just don't think of the
exit that's a good uh piece of advice
so after fear perseverance
constancy in doing something despite
difficulty or delay in achieving success
you know it's one of those things seems
real obvious right yeah you say this if
courage is the ability to effectively
move through fear challenge or
discomfort then perseverance is the
ability to keep doing it over and over
again to persevere though does not mean
simply to endure every challenge every
uncomfortable situation and fearful
episode has its own Contours some might
require only stoicism acquire a quiet
suffering until the moment passes others
might call for an active aggressive
response
those are two you know you get the
situations where dude you're just
hanging on you're just gonna like suck
it up yeah yeah well I talk about there
I break that's one of the attributes I
break into a couple different things
right and so perseverance is actually a
combination of both persistence and
tenacity and with a little mental
fortitude thrown in the mix right but
but persistence is hey I'm going to uh
do this thing the same thing until it's
accomplished I know it's the rock it's
the stonecutter approach I'm going to
tap on this rock 100 times because I
know in the 100 first half it's gonna
break uh tenacity is I'm gonna try
something if it doesn't work I'm going
to try something else if that doesn't
work and so so you don't want a
tenacious stone cutter right you'll
never get the Rock Cut and you don't
want a persistent car mechanic who just
checks the belts and checks the belts
and checks but what perseverance allows
you to do is allows you to modulate in
between those two and we all know that
any environment might require either uh
and and the the kind of the mental
fortitude pieces can I decide which but
um but yeah it's this ability to just
keep stepping through and modulate
yourself as you go through
you know you get into this at some point
in the book um you know and I wrote a
book called dichotomy leadership with
life life and it was the idea that if
you take any of these we weren't calling
them attributes but if you take any
characteristic of a human and you take
it to an extreme it's probably gonna be
a problem yes 100 and you know one of
the examples that I wrote about
leadership strategy and tactics is this
is something that when I was running
training
we'd put these guys like in a hallway
you know and at the end of the hallway
there'd be a barricaded shooter and the
platoon Commander be like two guys go
those two guys get shot up with
paintball they're dead two more guys go
those two guys good and you'll have
those guys stuck in that mindset of
number one they've been trained to never
quit their whole life
and all you have to do is step back like
two feet look around and be like oh and
you know I sometimes I have to be like
hey man how many more guys you're gonna
send to their to their death
do you think there's maybe another way
to get to that room besides this Hall
this one hallway there that you're in
right now and it was amazing how tunnel
visioned people get
inexperienced guys you know platoon
Chief like the guy's got 15 years in
like two more go two more go you're like
hey man
flank this dude man just go outside
throw the grenade in the window do
something else so that the idea of and I
think when I wrote about it in um
leadership strategy and tactics I think
that's called the chapter like when to
quit
this is not it's not working out man you
might want to try something new stop
what you're doing I want to be tenacious
versus persistent on that one yeah
uh another one adaptability
the ability to quickly and calmly adjust
to changing circumstances in situations
and you have a little Ode to the Frog
here yep chapter six is called be like
the Frog
um adaptability has amphibians frogs are
built to live a double life if it isn't
safe or suitable on land
they can hop into the water
nothing to eat in the pond to wander out
and land and grab a bite frogs have
adapted to environments on every
continent except Antarctica from
low-lying deserts to the slopes of
mountains at fifteen thousand feet
you know in the Australian Outback the
water holding frog can wait up to seven
years for rain damn
uh thanks they're cold blood frogs can
change their body temperature to adjust
the temperature to the surroundings and
their legs provide a Mobility that is
extremely advantageous allowing them to
LEAP up to 20 times their body length
the evolution of frogs of course is
classic Darwinism survival doesn't
necessarily favor the strongest
fat a lot of good that did the T-Rex but
rather those life forms that are most
adaptable this is the same for us and
therein lies the secret to making
through buds it's not about being the
strongest right you have to adapt
yourself and um
to whatever's going on so I mean we're
all all Team guys have are high on
adaptability I think um because we can
uh we can just the environment changes
and we just okay how do I adjust you
know you know you don't fight it you
adjust to it yeah I should have brought
you this book uh I did I think I did
four or five podcasts on this book
called the psychology of military
incompetence and it's written by this
guy who is a World War II guy who became
a psychologist and he wrote this
freaking awesome book but one of the
main dynamics of the book is that when
you look at the military from the
outside
you know if you're a young sort of
person with an authoritarian mindset and
you like things to be a certain way you
look at the military and you're like oh
that's the place I need to be people
have to listen to me everyone's gonna
look the same everyone's gonna have to
wear the same stuff everyone's gonna
have to do what I tell them to do it's a
really promising looking environment
when you have an authoritarian mindset
and that authoritarian mindset
in Garrison works out really well we're
on the drill team yeah on the drill team
it works out well but man when you don't
have that open mind and the adaptability
and you get into combat where all of a
sudden things aren't going to go the way
you want them to go it's going to be
Mayhem yes and you can't and people that
have trouble adapting to it are going to
be not good combat leaders so I've
always there'd always be some of those
uh folks growing into buds a lot of
times um
I shouldn't say a lot of times but I've
heard stories of guys that were prior
Marines prior Army you know had and and
squared away like these guys dude
infantry officer a special operations
guy from the Army whatever
but those environments the Marine Corps
in the army
they have a they're they're going to
favor someone that has a little bit more
authoritarian mindset yeah yeah and they
show up the buds and they're like this
is freaking Mayhem right and they don't
even they don't like it it's too crazy
for them yeah it's too chaotic this is
not all army guys it's not all Marines
I'm just saying I've heard stories of
guys like oh what I heard that that guy
was you know that guy was a freaking uh
opportune commander in Iraq in the Army
what happened they'd be like oh dude he
just he just it was too crazy yeah it's
too uh it's a structure thing right and
so I talk you know we'll probably get
into cunning I mean but this is Team
guys we all hate rules you know I mean
and um and so we actually like lack of
structure in many cases it can be our
downfall it has been as leadership as
leaders in the teams we have to actually
monitor that because it can go awry
quite quickly but um but it's this
looseness that we approach environments
to because again one of the things that
you learn and I always say people ask me
a lot of times hey how does how do Navy
Seals stay humble right and I say well
listen there are some seals who aren't
very humble but most of us for the most
part are humble do foods and I said the
biggest the most the primary reason is
because we're in environments that will
kill us right I don't care what kind of
swimmer you are the ocean will kill you
if you if you turn your back on it right
same with uh jumping out of airplanes of
22 000 feet I used to tell my guys you
know Somalia a nine-year-old with an
AK-47 and just pull the trigger and it
just happens to aim will kill a 35 year
old expert Navy Seal in a second with a
with an unaimed shot right so so so in a
world where the environment requires
deep humility and the ocean's just a
perfect example I mean look you surf
right I mean when you get when you get
you get churned up by a wave what do you
do you relax you just let the you kind
of you go with it you don't fight it you
adapt to the water right and so so I
think this is a huge asset in in um in
in any type of uncertainty uh and just
like you said any of these attributes
over indexed is a bad thing too much
adaptability means your limp noodle
right yeah um and so and so in fact what
we're doing to do right now in the work
we do with organizations we're taking
each attribute and we have about 46 now
and we're actually defining okay what
does too much look like what does too
little look like because it's a pretty
cool project yeah that's that's uh we at
at my company we do the same thing we we
do a balance assessment and like where
are you out of balance do you
micromanage to a point where people have
no say in what's happening or are you
too far in the other direction where now
no one knows what's going on right and
we do that with every characteristic of
leadership so yeah yeah balance and not
being extreme that was the the bummer
about our book extreme ownership is we
put the term extreme assumption
no actually we'll run another book to to
make up for that right right uh next one
resilience
the ability to rapidly return to one's
Baseline emotional and mental state
after a stressful traumatic or even
triumphant event and you've got a story
in here and get the book to read the
story about your uh buddy Hank who was
who was uh wounded badly in Afghanistan
and you just talk about his resilience
um yeah you got to meet Hank uh just an
awesome guy um I was trying to I was
actually I was reading about I was like
who is this guy yeah I was trying to
because he he was your troop sea yeah
you may know him we'll talk we'll go
offline but uh but yeah yeah I was I was
figuring I mean he's got to be I mean if
he was in for the same time period he's
got to be around yeah my time frame
actually yeah he was yeah so we'll talk
offline about that but you have a great
great story about him obviously a very
inspiring story and it's a legit story
of resiliency
um
but this is an interesting way of
looking at it you say this uh imagine
your life represented by a line plotted
on a page line moves from left to right
from the past into the present extends a
little bit more with each passing day if
your life was uniformly calm and
pleasant neither aggravating nor
exciting the line would be flat and
level we'll call that your Baseline and
it's where you're at it's where you're
most comfortable emotionally mentally
and physically but the line is rarely
flat of course it undulates rising and
falling in an irregular wave to mirror
the highs and lows of your life
occasionally the line spikes
representing your greatest achievements
and sometimes it plummets maybe your
spouse divorces you or maybe you get
fired
it's difficult to function in either of
those deep troughs or at those dizzying
Peaks what you want what you need is to
return to the Baseline to that state of
pleasant calm that's neither aggravating
nor exciting
that's what it means to be resilient
and you got a story in here from one of
your Skippers
who who you know who I will say because
we you mentioned in one that were Craven
Pete van Hoosier
um when I mentioned him when mccraven
was on uh I mean one of the best
officers I mean and I was so fortunate
he was my CEO when I was running
training got it um and yeah he used to
talk about the two-minute Rule and um
you know he said my grandfather taught
it to me and uh you know something bad
happens take two minutes and just you
know wallow swear whatever you need to
kick the dirt you know feel sorry for
yourself after two minutes get back to
work something good happens
celebrate rest on your laurels pat
yourself on the back after two minutes
get back to work you know um and it's
such and again I people say because I've
put this on social media I've gotten
some people like well it takes a lot
more to than two minutes there's a lot
of things in life that take a lot more
than two minutes to come back to
baseline from but but the two minute
rule allows you practice in those small
tragedies you know that you might have
um and practice the resilience muscle
and again resilience is necessarily
growth through a growth to to grow from
something like that takes a little bit
more effort
um and you can kind of you can up that
Baseline into some other stuff that
Hebrew and I were working on as well
um but resilience if you can get back to
Baseline you know then you you are
you're getting yourself back into a
steady state where you cannot start
making decisions again and I think
that's another thing that Navy Seals do
very well as we get better we get
ourselves back to Baseline
um sometimes to our detriment because if
we come back because we might come back
from the lows so fast that we don't
allow ourselves the appropriate healing
time for that to happen but you know
again
sometimes we have to if we're in a
combat environment you know we have to
get back right but uh but resilience is
also often conflated with perseverance
you know but resilience is not
perseverance perseverance is moving
through and and going through resilience
is snapping back it's that rubber band
stretching and then going back to the
original shape so would it be a uh how
does this play out I'm imagining what
what the answer is but when you have
someone that's really good with
perseverance but not really good with
resilience so they're in a bad place but
they keep going
you gotta keep going but what happens is
they slowly they slowly fall into
entropy there so if you imagine so the
way you look if people imagine that line
and that sine wave at a nice sine wave
that kind of goes up and down and stays
that with that with that line Center
someone who does not is not resilient
will that but that that curve is going
to go down and that line will so it will
fall so you'll fall into entropy whereas
if you can become anti-fragile you can
actually get that line you can actually
have that that curve start moving up and
that line starts moving up right yeah so
any one of these one of the cool things
that I you know was exploring continue
to and the way I actually distinguish
these attributes is can they exist
independently of each other so can you
be perseverant without being resilient
and the answer is absolutely yes can you
be resilient without being perseverant
yes
um so uh but and there's there's
manifestations of each of those those
combinations yeah no that's kind of what
I thought that's why I said I can
imagine what the answer is yeah and the
reason I think this is because I think
you and I both have known guys where
they're going to keep going yes but you
can see that they're not
they're not where they should be they're
going to keep going they're going to
keep going unemployment they're going to
keep working they're going to keep
driving forward but everything's falling
apart yes I think I think out of all the
grit attributes resilience is where a
lot of Team guys fall short and you
actually see it in the in the civilian
sector with very high performers and
there's a reason the reason is because
High performers to include Team guys
love the uh love the feeling of getting
getting the [__] done oh God I got it
done right what's the next thing okay
give me the next thing give me the next
thing and resilience one of the things
resilience requires is a recovery it
requires a an assemblance of recovery to
get back to Baseline if you maximize
that recovery you'll get to
anti-fragility but you at least need
enough recovery to get back to Baseline
a lot of top performers fall into the
Trap of not recovering and we know
Team guys are pretty bad at that yeah
uh next set of attributes that you talk
about is the mental acuity attributes
mental acuity is basically a measure of
how sharp the mind is it has little do
with education or even raw intelligence
it's not a matter of how well-read or
quick-witted you are rather we're
focusing on the ability to effectively
absorb and understand information to
concentrate focus and remember
you give some uh some definitions in
here this is via huberman yeah
um we talked a lot while I was putting
this one together I'm sure you did
you've got scripts these are think of
these are the lines of code your brain
is constantly writing to make sense of
the world you've got patterns these are
collections of similar scripts that
build familiarity and certainty in our
environment
such as every time I touch a hot stove I
get burnt patterns are how we learn
categories the hippocampus which is in
charge of long-term memory groups
patterns into categories for easier
retrieval
using a stove climbing a tree driving my
car and then contacts these are broad
versions of the categories cooking
climbing driving
and they can be applied to a variety of
environments for example and this I
thought this was a great example if you
jump on a tractor or slip into a go-kart
or Take The Wheel of a boat your brain
will recognize that context as driving
so these are they it gets it gets
complex that's why you know you write a
book and I recognize I wrote that book
and afterwards I got this is pretty
dense and you have people who resonate
with some of the details my wife right
she's like there's too much Neuroscience
in here I don't like that part right
um other people like I love the
Neuroscience I think when you talk about
those definitions it speaks to mostly
that task switching capability our
brains our Focus points and we're
hopping between category contexts and
categories of all the time
um ultimately these attributes just
describe how we process the world around
us and they're my favorite because I
think even though I would say
compartmentalization is the number one
thing you need at steel training it's
that it's really the mental acuity
attributes that start defining how you
perform in stress challenge uncertainty
and so and so we start going through
those like situation awareness
compartmentalization task switching
um how's our brain working in those
environments and and how quickly and
effectively are we able to do certain
things and there's pros and cons for
both so
the one you just mentioned the first one
of these situational awareness the
ability to absorb and process meaningful
information about our current
environment yeah and man this is in
short vigilance right yeah yeah yeah and
then you know you get into and and you
get into this as well
um
the fact that you know here's what you
say as with any attribute extremes can
be detrimental like I said you get into
it yourself you know I wrote a book
about it this book has it as well
extremes can be detrimental too little
situational awareness risks Oblivion
obliviousness to real danger too much
hyper or hyper vigilance can wear out
the nervous system and perhaps even mask
an underlying paranoia so this is this
is the um seeds oftentimes with PTSD for
those of us coming back from the combat
zone um I mean I'm someone who literally
walks around New York City I love New
York City right I walk around I notice
everything I notice dark alleys I notice
hands I notice faces I notice cars you
know everything and my wife's not next
to me and she doesn't notice anything
right and now again let me just make
sure I set the context all of us have
all of these attributes the difference
in each one of us are the levels to
which we have each right so so
adaptability right um I you and I would
be a level eight environment changes
around us we we shift okay someone else
might be level three it's difficult for
them they're still adaptable it's just
difficult so and if we were kind of
lying all these up like a dimmer switch
on a wall we'd all have different dimmer
switch settings as to where these things
fall which starts to speak to our
performance okay so there's no judgment
in this right it's like be like judging
your hair color it's just who you are
um so when I say I'm
we all seals tend to be you know very
high high situational horse we're pretty
Vigilant and when you go to a combat
zone as you know
um you're wired I mean you get you get
height I mean everything you just notice
everything you're on key and so when you
go home if you can't turn that off
that's when you're walking around New
York City I was like okay there's a guy
like two feet behind me I can't and he
can't it's like okay it's gonna be okay
right so so I've I made I had I took
deliberate efforts a lot of times to
just freaking relax
what efforts did you take just to just
to recognize where I was being too hyper
Vigilant and say don't worry about it
it's going to be fine right
um and and in some cases just enjoy the
moment of obliviousness you know uh put
my headphones on maybe a couple times
which is hard for me like like I'm like
you I don't run with headphones because
usually because I like the environment
but I see people running with headphones
on the street I'm like what the hell are
you thinking I mean you're gonna put one
ear in that's it yeah two years and I've
never I no that's not happening it's not
happening yeah my sons do one do the one
earphone get their headphone but uh but
anyway I think um
uh situation awareness again too much is
hyper sees a PTSD too little oh I mean
you're not going to notice stuff and
that's it's important too sometimes so
yeah um it's weird too I was thinking
like your wife if you you're in New York
City she's with you her vigilance is way
low but I bet you walk out of the
grocery store at night to your car Which
is far across the parking lot you're not
thinking that much about it your wife
the other hand you know walking out at
night from the grocery store to the car
she's probably more Vigilant than you
are just because there's a she probably
perceived threats higher yeah threat I
think threat definitely definitely
affects this and um and this is where it
gets attributes get interesting because
context matters um and I think what the
best way to describe this in a general
sense is where you default to you know
and and I just I default to noticing
stuff I mean just it's just who we are
uh I just noticed actually human right
human and I were joking about this we
were traveling this is well before code
we were traveling to do a talk and so we
happened to be traveling together and um
and we show up and and I'm just like
okay we gotta go here here I know what's
in my bag I know I get through security
like everything's just I just know I've
I've thought through everything and
and I think I did TSA pre-check too
meanwhile he goes through the regular
security and I walk over to see where he
is and his bag is completely opened up
security guards ticket you know there's
protein powder and all that stuff and we
were joking about that because we're
just we're just constantly thinking that
way you know noticing stuff so yeah
so this is the one that you've mentioned
already several times
compartmentalization the ability to
effectively
chunk an environment or situation into
meaningful pieces then focus on that
which needs immediate attention and
again in the book extreme ownership is
we call this prioritize and execute yeah
you've got to focus on what's Happening
um
compartmentalization is a three-step
process assessment prioritization and
then Focus so you know for me it was
prioritized and execute you know it's
interesting one of the stories that I
tell in the book is uh Seth Stone was
the platoon Commander I was tasking a
commander and we're out doing vehicle
immediate action drills and when the
guns with the guns would start shooting
the targets would pop up he would like
lock up you know this is just we're in
our workup yeah and I'm watching him and
he's not making a call and so I took my
Sharpie magic marker and I like we got
done to the run I was like hey bro next
time I want you to do this and I wrote
one like on on the windscreen uh or the
windshield of his Humvee I wrote One
relax two look around three make a call
I said when you hit those Gun starts
shooting again just follow these steps
yeah and he's like Roger that yeah and
so then sure enough you know I'm like
sitting behind him in the vehicle the
targets pop up and the shooting starts
and I I'm looking at him and I see him
like you can't hear anything because the
50 Cal's going but I look at him and I
see him like take a breath and exhale
I'm like okay cool he's got step one
he's relaxing and then he looks around
he opens the door looks at the vehicle's
behind him like okay there's two and he
gets on the on the horn and makes a call
I was like there you go
um that was kind of the original version
of prioritize and execute and and also
taking a step back like you got to take
a step back you got to relax and look
around and make a call and that's what
that's what you're talking about here
well and compartmentalization doesn't
work without situation awareness I mean
and that's so what you're talking about
is that that stepping back as you're
stepping back you're getting a situation
you're aware again and then you're
compartmentalizing and then you're
getting a situation away this is that
that out in motion and they just work in
tandem in the best way yeah it's such a
freaking cheat code oh my God it's such
a cheat code and again another Seth
Stone story so he broke his neck during
workup I remember hearing that yeah and
so now he can't do land Warfare
but I'm like hey bro let's you know come
out I'm going out to to do ftx's with
your guys I'm going out to watch him he
likes to come out with me he's like of
course so we're standing there and his
guys are pinned down we got the the
laser tag system on and his guys are
pinned down in this Ravine and he's like
let me help him and I was like no and
we're literally standing like a foot
away from these guys and it's so obvious
what call needs to be made it's just
completely obvious yeah and no one's
making the call they're all looking down
their gun and yelling and screaming and
just it's just chaos and finally you
know go ahead and help him and he tells
them hey do this I had or whatever
and he looks at me once they're out he
goes man it's so easy from way up here
yeah and I was like bro look where we
are I go you know what this was like for
me when we went through work up together
I said everything was like this because
I was never freaking staring down the
barrel of my gun or the sights of my
weapon like freaking out I was just like
looking around oh yeah there's there's
an out over there cool we could oh I see
the bad guys we don't want to go in that
direction but hey let's do this maneuver
and it's just really easy it's like a
freaking superpower yeah the Detachment
that's right that's right
um so you go into this
compartmentalization and also worth
noting you say this is an endless
process compartmentalization is not
static if you Silo your thoughts into a
tight box and keep them there or sorry
as if you Silo your thoughts and keep
them there it's ever changing the script
is constantly updating with information
and we actually have a word for this in
the military
Target fixation yes right this is like
oh you're gonna prioritize and execute
but then you forget about everything
else now you've only got one thing
you're looking at yeah we call that
Target fixation
yeah leader should not be doing that
yeah
um
the multitasking myth this is chapter 10
task switching
the ability to shift Focus among tasks
or contexts most people believe they can
multitask most people in fact believe
they're very good at it in one famous
study from the University of Utah a
statistically absurd but remarkable
confident markedly confident 70 percent
of participants thought they were above
average in their ability to win multiple
things at once they weren't and you
aren't either
when people try to do several things at
once almost everyone a full 98 according
to the Utah study gets worse at each
individual task another study at
Stanford found that people who
habitually multitask actually do more
poorly over time
so this is this again falls into
compartmentalization because if you're
not prioritizing and executing and
you're trying to do a bunch of things at
the same time you're actually going to
fail at all of them yeah and a
recognition that we just we can't focus
on more than one thing I mean we just
can't and so and again people people
will be listening to this podcast and
say You Know Rich and Jocko you're full
of it because I'm listening to this
podcast and driving my car right it
doesn't count if you've relegated that
task to your unconscious mind you can do
that because you don't have to think
about driving your car but if you're
listening to this podcast driving your
car and someone swerves in front of you
and you have to take evasive maneuvers
you'll have to rewind the last 15
seconds of the podcast because your
brain will have hopped context right and
so and so the people so there are some
people who are really good at this you
know who can go from the email to the
conversation to this to that and go all
around and just hop really effectively
other people when they when they get hop
or get hopped it takes them a while for
their brain to kind of engage in that
new activity and so and so it's really
just about understanding Where You Are
um I just realized I do something Echo
Charles you're not gonna like this
because I've probably done it to you
before I don't doubt it so let's say
we're rolling you me rolling Jiu Jitsu
we're struggling right
and all of a sudden I just like start
having a conversation with someone or
like or like I go or you know like we're
rolling and all of a sudden I say to
someone that's else that's carrying on a
conversation somewhere else and I go I
say uh you know actually no there's no
class this afternoon yeah yeah chiming
in and I'm doing that I literally do
that psychological warfare yeah to let
you know that whatever you're doing
right now I'm not even thinking about
it's kind of a joke yes I know that okay
you're fully aware of your intention too
so it kind of like mitigated the effects
a little bit it's like the ultimate cool
guy thing yeah but a lot of people do
that and it's kind of like because some
Jiu Jitsu is like that I just kind of
gave up someone like I know now you know
what he's not the only person that do it
yeah I already knew he did that yeah he
does other stuff too it's way more mean
but it's uh but this is the kind where
sometimes you can do that because it's a
lot of it's just natural you know muscle
memory whatever and so you can see you
know especially in the early rounds
where you're warming up or whatever like
people do it and that's kind of the
reason and he'll do it because it's kind
of like oh I don't even have to think
when I roll with you they just relegate
to the subconscious right I don't really
see what you're doing
yeah yeah that's good that's what made
me think about when you're like oh you
can drive a car you'll have to rewind to
15 seconds so you know you had to think
about it I don't think about what you're
doing so now watch next time he does
that stuff I'm I'm gonna like go hard or
whatever increase his sense of urgency
yeah you got to interrupt his little
psychological thing yeah there you go
um
this is the one the the between that one
and so the compartmentalization thing
you talked about for buds for basic SEAL
training it's just like oh you just need
to focus on whatever you're doing right
in front of you right now right yeah you
need to effectively move your horizons
yeah and but and the focus of this one
is the task switching so recognizing
that you can't do two things at the same
time you need to focus on this one yeah
and if you have to focus on the other
thing
go ahead and focus on that other thing
so so it gets this is where it gets fun
a little bit complex is that the people
who do this very well and what we've
seen in our environment can um can
compartmentalize while keeping a little
bit of situation awareness to the
environment because because as they as
we monitor the environments at least and
and actually here removal will will
testify to this in terms of the human
brain can't necessarily focus on two
things at once but it can keep awareness
of a second thing while you're focused
on one thing and so and so we keep
awareness because if if in that
awareness the priorities change then we
task switch right and we we say oh now
the new priority we're coming off of
this even though it's incomplete and
shifting that is Shifting to a new
priority so so they they can they can
dance these attributes can dance with
each other and I don't know what the
optimal levels are for you know a seal
or someone you know depending I would I
would imagine fighting is the same way
because you're you're constantly gauging
the environment and you might be focused
on one move but you're gauging what
what's happening you may have to shift
or adapt but these types of
these types of exercises can allow for
for a good uh practice of these one of
the
um
one of the things that I think it's
really useful to be able to do is like
press into an issue
and this is what I used to tell the
young seal officers that were going
through my training I'd be like hey you
might need to get in there and solve a
problem don't stay there right like get
in there look in that room look in that
building look at that what that Squad is
doing make the adjustment and then get
back out of there and now I I well with
the ooda loop when when people fail with
the ooda loop it's because they get
stuck in one piece of that right they're
looking around too much they're not
making a decision or they can't figure
out what decision to make or once they
make a decision they don't act on it I
also do this whole uh leadership Loop of
decision making and the final point that
I make is don't get stuck in any one of
these things because then you're stuck
in that one thing yeah so the ability to
press in look at a problem solve the
problem give them give a direction give
a solution and then get out of there is
is is a key to anything that you're
doing really is from a leadership
perspective the minute and there's
another thing I've been saying a lot
later the solution to the problem is not
in the problem like you're you can go in
there to figure out what the problem is
and then back out and find what the
solution is because most likely when
you're in that problem you're not gonna
you're not gonna see this you're in the
Fishbowl yeah that's like when you're up
in the catwalks you know you're watching
when you're watching other people do CQC
that's like so easy from up here when
you're watching somebody do an IED
you're like oh there's the out over
there or that's where that's where they
should flank to you can actually get
there
while you're doing it as long as you
exercise that Detachment and taking a
step back and looking around so
important this is what uh again the the
advantage I mean again I think you you
would agree with the war sucks on all
levels um but the advantage of being
able to uh be in combat or or be at
these these units where we're learning
this stuff
um if you're not doing this as a leader
you're you're out of the game you're
gonna be outrun I mean you have to you
recognize that this is your job your job
is not looking down the gun and pointing
and shooting I mean I I I may be kicked
a couple doors when I was out in Iraq
and Afghanistan because my job was
tasking a commander I was running the
environment and my guys expected me to
do that job because they they said hey
you do that very well right so so the
job is to maintain that awareness so
that the guys who have to be Target
fixated for a little while can do so and
understand that their backs are covered
yeah
um learnability the ability to observe
process and apply new and from
information to a current or future
context among the mental acuity
attributes the most important is
learnability it's a sort of catalyst
that allows those other cognitive traits
to be put into effective use if we
didn't have the ability to update and
adjust the scripts our brains are
constantly writing or apply and remember
the appropriate patterns and templates
that is to learn
and compartmentalization and task
switching would only help make us make
the same mistakes more efficiently so if
you're not looking at what's going on
and actually adjusting to what's
happening then although it doesn't
matter if you're compartmentalizing
you're not learning anything well and I
would say this is actually one that I
admit that I'm a little lower on um
because the the people who are really
high on learnability other people you
can tell how to do something once or
show them once and they got it right
they just they pick up things really
fast and I for me well it was budge but
probably more the the selection when I
was going through it and when we
finished a day of training and there'd
be guys there they're clean their gear
and go drinking I'd have to stay back
and like think about what I did and and
I'd make the same mistakes a couple
times and so it's really it's an
adjustment to where you are
um but if we're not if we're not able to
recognize where we fall on this
particular attribute it's going to be
tough to actually metabolize these
lessons
I think something that I learned
watching when I was a young guy and I'd
see guys that were older than me you
know with experience that have two
platoons or five platoons or whatever
and they would be this is the way you do
it something whether it was a room entry
whether it was immediate action drill
whether it was you know how to put your
weapon at high Port lope or whatever
there was a way that they had
been taught
and in their minds that was the only way
to do it yeah it's the only way to do it
they usually couldn't articulate why
their way was better
they would usually use their rank or
their Authority their experience to say
no I've always done it this way this is
the way we learn
and I remember I'll have to try and try
and remember where this kind of lesson
solidified but I remember thinking
myself I'm not going to be like that
and there is definitely a hundred
percent more than one way to skin a cat
like you go into a room you can do 28
different things and they can all be
right yeah like you can go you could go
left you go right there's a bunch of
different ways to do things
and to to get stuck on
one way and not ever
make adjustments
to me that's a lack of learnability 100
well so when I got to stvs you know
again late 90s we had as you recognize
when you're at Seal Team too a bunch of
the old Vietnam guys were still in the
teams great dudes most of them running
training and I remember we did a we did
an island trip
um as stvs because we're going to deploy
out to the Middle East and so we're
doing this insane like seven day hump or
whatever and they're they're contacting
us and things like that and they're
contacting Us in open terrain middle of
the desert right and they're like okay
peel right or peel plf they're using
Vietnam like channelized you know
tactics in an open desert and I remember
thinking that doesn't it just doesn't
compute right now I mean are there other
ways to do that and in fact the teams
sort of see that too I remember you
probably remember IMT the whole IMT
stuff right that that came from or at
least when I saw it or it would seem to
be born from this idea that hey we need
to start learning how to move in a
different way because yes some of these
channelized tactics are great they work
for jungles but you know we need some
different tactics but this is the
dinosaur mentality we always you know
are combating yeah there's been some
there there definitely was some um
strange Evolutions that happen and I
mean literal Evolutions uh you didn't go
to OCS um I went to OCS and when I went
to OCS they had uh you had to polish
your you got to issue these belt buckles
their brass belt they're some kind of
brass right and they came with this
coating on it that meant it didn't erode
right it just stayed beautiful in China
yeah yeah and when you got it issued to
you they would make you polish that
thing until that enamel came off and now
it could erode and I remember thinking
myself like this lost its this law this
got lost somewhere yeah
uh the iads so as you know at our land
Warfare on the west coast the desert
training facility there's areas in there
that are closed terrain yes you can go
and you can do jungle tactics and close
Terrain
and what what happened is
some things over time
they lost they got lost and I'll give
you a great example
um
when you're doing for instance like a
like a peel right
and when you do appeal right
you ever you ever seen that thing where
it looks like you're doing a pirouette
they call it which is like a dance move
you spin around yes so you'd be like if
you're gonna peel right or if you're
gonna peel left and it was your turn to
go you would turn the opposite direction
spin around yeah like an about face you
know and so
if you're on a range in America there's
almost no place where you can do what
you're actually supposed to do and the
Vietnam guys
no this got me I missed this for like my
first platoon I was like I didn't really
understand I said hey why are we doing
this Spin and guys it's for safety and I
was like okay I didn't really understand
why this was safer maybe you're kind of
high porting or whatever
and then a Vietnam guy was you know I
asked a Vietnam guy
I was actually I think it was Roger
Hayden
and uh I was like why do you spin like
this why don't you just get up and go
and he goes oh if you weren't on a range
right now
if you were if you had 360 degree
you would when you got done shooting at
the Target you would then turn to your
right and dump more rounds On Your Flank
then you would turn behind you and dump
rounds behind you to make sure that
you're not getting someone behind you
and then you tag your next guy and go
so what it looks like when you can't
shoot is it looks like you're just
spinning for no reason
and so that's I've explained that to
many many people over the years like oh
here's what's actually supposed to be
happening you're supposed to be doing
this so what happened is when you got
guys that went from like doing the
um closed Terrain
where you can move because you're behind
cover and concealment right well when
you're in the desert it's a long way to
travel and so what do you do well well
just kind of going through the motions
so in order to go through the motions
just get up and run
and that became a thing and it's like
um that does why doesn't that feel right
well it doesn't feel right because it's
not right now listen if you're it if
you're half distance and you have cover
fire sometimes it does the right thing
to do and you can you've got guys
putting down massive cover fire hey you
get up and move you're trying to get out
of there but yeah there's some of those
things that over time they the next
thing you know you're polishing the
enamel off your belt buckle that's right
and and things just get lost in
translation over time that's one of the
negatives about not having Doctrine like
we talked about earlier knowing to say
hey the reason that you spin like that
is if you were in a real contact in a
closed environment you'd be dumping
rounds so that you're not getting
flanked and you're not getting anyone
coming up your six which is what you
know there's when you're online in a
gunfight everyone's online facing in One
Direction yeah so Somebody's gotta
occasionally dump some rounds behind you
make sure no one's crawling up your ass
which is going to be a bad scene I'm
really appreciative because I never knew
that so I've I've learned that now after
21 years the Navy yeah and again I got
lucky like caught that and I always had
those questions you know like wait a
second why are we doing this wait why
does that yeah what's that where's that
come from and yeah usually there was a
reason and unfortunately sometimes they
would get lost in the translation over
time which is
which is terrible yeah um yeah and then
a lot of lessons we relearned in in in
our war
um
right on what do we got next here after
learnability a drive I think
the drive attributes
we all have needs and the drive is how
we try to fulfill them if you're hungry
and thirsty to use the easiest examples
you are driven to find food and water
those are admittedly much easier tasks
now that we can satisfy this needs by
opening a refrigerator and turning on
the tap but for many Millennia eating
and drinking required expending a
considerable amount of time and energy
the more driven among our ancestors or
the least hungry and thirsty
there are two kinds of human needs
intrinsic and extrinsic
explain those to me intrinsic and
extrins well it's from Dan Pink's uh
book drive so the intrinsic needs are
those um
those you can almost talk about like a
physiological needs I mean the drive to
drink is from a physiological need to to
uh to because you're thirsty you need
water extrinsic are those
um you know I need to I need to make
money to pay my rent right so so they're
just coming from the external
environments um but uh but yeah Drive
the drive as opposed to grit I mean a
grid I would Define as that that ability
to kind of set and pursue those shorter
term or acute challenges and objectives
and then drive as those longer term
challenges and objectives I mean what
are those what makes up the driven
person what are those attributes
um and there's some counterintuitive
ones in there so
um
self-efficacy
a belief in one's ability to achieve a
goal especially when the path is
uncertain or unknown and you have this
chapter titled this chapter about
self-efficacy is titled uh mastering the
pivot you say like some other attributes
self-efficacy can be
dissected into components It's a
combination of confidence initiative and
optimism I I like these little I like
that um as soon as I read that I was
like that's a good a good way of
explaining it it's not as simple as I
got this that's usually bravado
self-efficacy is thoughtful and serious
it's I know I can do this because I'm
willing to take the first step and even
though I don't know yet all the answers
or how this will unfold I'll continue
until I'm successful
and then you go through talking about
confidence talk about initiative and
talk about optimism yeah and it's really
interesting to try and you know if
you're if you're entering any kind of
pursuit in life yeah and you think all
right how confident about this can I
take the first move and
in order to take that first move you got
to have that optimism that tracks are
going to make it happen you do and and
so we we we throw those other attributes
into our mix when we're doing this stuff
with with organizations because all all
these attributes are meaningful but but
they can be inert by the by themselves
you know I I talk about in the book I
mean you know I've always wanted to be a
pilot and my dad was a pilot my brother
was pilot I know pretty much at this
point I could fly an airplane I know
everything about flying I've been
through Ground School a couple times I
mean I know everything like again I got
my brother Sim and I could fly the thing
right I've never gotten my Pilots
license I'm confident I could fly a
plane I've never gotten my pilot's
license right so there's lack of
initiative there
um and so initiative on its own is
frenetic energy I mean you just you know
oh I'm just gonna go right but if
there's no if there's no confidence if
there's no optimism you're just you're
just expending energy and then optimism
on its own I mean you and I could plant
Gardens and and say every day that weeds
are not going to grow
um and I'm sure you know sure enough
three weeks later weeds will grow so so
optimism on its own can be inert um and
so it's really the combination that
makes up the self efficacious person and
and if you have if you have an optimal
level of that you will that that adds to
your drive quite a bit there's got to be
I we had a a friend of mine Travis Mills
on this podcast and he's just a freaking
probably the best human ever I don't
know
who he is he's a quadruple amputee from
Afghanistan I've heard of him he's his
attitude is Bar None better than anybody
anyone I've ever known I mean just
absolutely freaking awesome guy and we
are talking you know we're going through
his life and his history and he joined
the army and you know we're talking and
you know he like was a stud in high
school freaking football athlete just a
stud and he's a beast of a human just a
total stud
and I kind of was like hey man why
didn't you go and like you know like why
don't you try for Special Forces or you
can go ranger or anything like that and
he goes man I didn't know if I could
make it and like this guy is I mean I
was the most
average person like the most average
high school kid across the board like
average to low average and every thing
that I did I was just like but for some
reason I had this idea like oh seal
trading toughest training in the world
why not let's go I'll bring it and you
have a total stud like Travis being like
I wasn't sure if I could make it so it's
like he he might have had a little
negative on the optimism right you know
right yeah there's a balance and but
there's also we can we'll throw throw a
little cutting in there we don't like
rules so don't tell me what to do uh
there's some Rebel nature in there um
that I think causes guys like you and I
to to try for seals uh and we'll talk
about this there's a little bit of
narcissism too yeah yeah
uh I have a question go so and
like Travis Mills you mentioned the
Travis milstein where he was like kind
of a higher level like a high level
athlete like in high school and stuff
and got used to it and we talked about
this about buds too with Jason Gardner a
little bit where he
was talking about you have high level
athletes who are really used to being
high level and winning winning right so
but then they go through bugs and they
start losing and then there it shatters
them right yeah and then you get someone
like how you just said like you're just
average so you're kind of used to doing
anything else
so do you think that it's like if you
kind of consider like why is that so
it's kind of like the the high level
athlete so to speak is used to a certain
standard of of what winning is I
wouldn't even say winning I would say I
would say I think it's a it's a level of
performance I mean the high level
athlete designs his or her entire day
and system
uh around being a hundred percent for
the moment right it's it's this idea of
a Peak Performance 100 for the moment
um and uh and so when they
come into an environment where 100
doesn't exist or they say oh great
you're 100 we're going to take it down
to zero right they're just not used to
it and so I think I think a lot of the
the the the div one athletes who go and
don't make it are just not used to being
at a performance level of of not 100 let
alone zero I was like you know we we
love to be 100 but like if someone came
to us before remission and said you know
what my um my shoulder's kind of 90 I
think I'm gonna sit this one out we're
like what are you talking about
it's more like telling a guy that like
has a freaking broken leg like hey bro
you can you cannot go I'm sorry
you know what is the difference between
rugby players and everybody else right
the seals are more like regular pillars
but yeah I think it's that it's that
level of performance so like the and and
not to put too fine of a tip on it but
so like let's say someone's who's so
used to winning and so used to
performing at their best more or less
it's almost like their level of standard
of what they would call success in their
mind is like so high so anything below
that threshold is kind of like oh I
might as well not even exist in this
environment I think I think you're onto
something again we can't we can't get
big in the minds of these folks but this
is again right you know I say I keep on
saying fighting like fighting is a is a
support you go into and you're literally
going in and expecting to get hurt
you're going to go I mean the whole game
is you're gonna go from 100 down to
whatever percent knocks you out right or
you're not got that other guy that is a
whole different mentality than a lot of
other sports right and so I think I
think these types of distinctions are
really interesting I mean aren't you
know you have to be careful you don't
put labels on things but um I don't know
I like dissecting that yeah that's the
scary thing too because whatever example
you bring up there's a counter example
yeah for every example you're like well
this guy was a stud and he quit and
there's a stud that made it yeah yeah
and there's a stud that failed whatever
and he was like yeah cool I got it like
well and there's just a counter there's
this counter to every example that you
can come up with yeah and I don't mean
necessarily like the whole guy right I'm
just saying that element yeah yeah if we
could die if we could figure those
things out then you start to be able to
figure out who's going to make it
through I think but you have to look at
the whole you can't just look at their
their life in athletics you'd have to
look at their whole life I mean because
there's because all those grid
attributes all those mentally good
adapters all those Drive activities
they're all executed in other areas of
life too I mean I talk about I mean
seals are gritty yeah but there are some
gritty people out there who are way
grittier than seals right I mean so so
these contexts of life can be training
and Proving Grounds for people and
Athletics that's why the the top athlete
might have had a a whole different
context inside of which he or she just
just nugged it out and was used to being
at zero and then they make it yeah that
would make sense with the wrestlers
because they're cutting weights and all
this like crazy starving themselves like
that so that would make sense and they
still quit by the way division one
resolution
yeah that's what happens actually I
heard a story from one of the
instructors was telling me like they had
a guy that was a total stud
like just an awesome fast freaking
strong just a stud and the they had like
they do things like uh put you on runs
where they're supposed to be four miles
but it's actually 4.6 or whatever or
they make you do a bunch of exercise
before and so they fail everybody
they'll let they'll let three guys pass
or whatever see those guys did it and
this guy like
I think it was like first day whatever
of first phase so he's gone through all
the pre-training
and then he felt they're like you fail
and he's like you got me I quit they
were like okay see ya which is it's
actually crazy when you think about guys
that sign up for the Navy enlisted the
Navy for six years of their life yeah
tell their girlfriend tell their parents
tell all the friends I'm gonna be a Navy
SEAL and they show up there in the first
day they freaking quit it's crazy it is
crazy I think part of that's the Mythos
though because because even even reading
about the training you read about how we
go you don't you just don't experience
until after hit the beaches that that
first day I was telling some young guy
the other day you know like
you know his dad or whatever someone
puts it was it was a family context like
like a family had met me or like a
father and son or something that and the
kid's like that's like he wants to be a
seal and I was like yeah you know uh
it's really hard most people don't make
it most people quit and um and he's like
looking at me as if bro you know I mean
what are you doing yeah I go and I go
and most people look at me like you're
looking at me right now like
clearly it's not gonna be I go I go
everyone shows up there thinking they're
gonna make it yeah and 80 of them ring
the bell so I wish you luck don't quit
that's my advice yeah I was I was in a
group of uh again good dudes or a
company we're working for about 10 of us
and they were all you know talking about
steel training and
um and almost all of them were like I'd
love to be a seal I I think I could do
it if I did I think I could do it I
think I could do it I looked at him I
said listen there's 10 people in here
okay about 85 quit so the uh and and I
already got through so the odds aren't
good for you 0.5 from one of you it's
gonna make it point five from what he
was gonna make it so
um all right here's a topic I'm always a
fan of discipline yes the ability to
remain focused and steadfast to achieve
a result but what's interesting this is
called the the chapter title is the
self-disciplined loser yes and what's
interesting is is Echo when I talk about
this you know people that have high
amounts of discipline
in certain areas and they just don't
apply it to other aspects of their life
it's that difference between what I call
outer and inner discipline so talk about
them yeah and so and so
the discipline I talk about in the book
is really outer discipline the that's
making uh uh choosing or or deciding
upon a goal uh that the outside world
has a say in whether or not you
accomplish okay that could be a Navy
SEAL writing a book becoming a
best-selling author being a great chef
whatever whatever that might be the
outside world has a say in whether or
not you can accomplish those so so the
so the discipline required to accomplish
that takes a different level it takes
adaptability it takes flexibility it
takes an understanding of you have to
shift you have to move right but then
there's self-discipline okay
self-discipline uh speaks to those goals
that the outside world has no say and
whether or not you accomplish so that's
like me saying I'm going to eat
healthier and I'm in Vegas next week
well I'm at the buffet the buffet is not
going to throw pastries at me okay it's
all on me all right
again this is where it gets interesting
because I ask myself can these exist
independently I have known people who
are highly self-disciplined they have a
routine they work out everything they
eat right blah blah they can't get a a
long-term goal accomplished for to save
their lives right I've seen people I'm
actually one of these who's I'm highly
disciplined like I can get audacious
goals accomplished you know and I'm good
at it right myself discipline sucks I
have to work on it it was really hard
for me right I always joke it's like I
don't even like to tell myself what to
do let alone you'll be told
um the best is a balance right but again
when you start separating these and
seeing that they can live independently
you start really understanding your
performance and so if you have the the
ability to say listen
I'm really high on self-discipline
because get a really high
self-discipline people love structure
they love routine guess what's going to
happen if you try to be a Navy SEAL or
be a best-selling author or be whatever
you name the outside goal your routine
is going to get screwed with you're not
going to be able to work out one day
you're not gonna be able to eat the same
thing you want to eat right so so that's
why they fall off the the the really
well-disciplined person people who have
audacious goals we're really good at
adapting we're like oh yeah throw it at
me now I'm good bro right but like now I
say hey you got to be structured it's
like oh don't tell me about director I
hate that right and so so obviously the
the the best the best is having a bounce
or at least understanding where you may
fall higher on Lower on those scales so
that you can affect you can affect each
side uh uh or affect each side
independently and get yourself to where
you need to go yeah I think uh you know
sorry I wrote a book called discipline
equals freedom field manual but I'll
talk about when I'm talking to companies
you know I'll talk about hey this is
dichotomy as well and inside of a team
if you're overly disciplined as a team
all of a sudden people don't they stop
thinking you know we can only follow the
rules you know the DMV in many ways is a
highly disciplined organization they're
going to follow that rule oh you're in
the wrong line go get in that other line
now they don't go hey cool hey we can
just move you over here I can do it this
time no they're highly disciplined and
therefore highly ineffective right so
you can go just like any of these things
you can take into an extreme and it's
gonna it's gonna cause problems someone
real quick someone asked me about once
uh about discipline equals Freedom so
what do you think about choco and
disability equal freedom and I said I
said he's absolutely right it's like the
only thing that we have to add on the
tagline is discipline equals freedom to
be undisciplined right
um because if you if you discipline
yourself to a degree you allow yourself
the freedom to once in a while be
undisciplined you know and that's the
dichotomy and it happens with teams as
well and this is the example that I give
all the time is if we're out on a Target
and there's another building that needs
to get taken down and I I can just look
you can go Rich go hit that building too
and you'd be cool got it you didn't need
to tell me the people you're going to
take or what method Adventure you're
going to use or what you're going to do
with the people that you captured you
didn't tell me that because we have
discipline standard operating procedures
which gave us all kinds of Freedom right
so we have the discipline which gives us
freedom to then move and maneuver
quicker and then on a personal level
this occurred for the first time I was
at this uh a kid's birthday party
little kids birthday party and they had
cake
and our ice cream cake which I think
that's one level up because cake won't a
lot of times cake cake is generally in
my opinion dry okay right sure the
frosting good but a lot of times the
cake itself dry it's not it's not enough
to bring me over the edge I understand
ice cream cake different stores right
okay so anyways the ice cream cake rolls
out the ice cream cake gets cut up and
I've slap of slab of that thing right on
my little plastic uh party plate and the
grandma
who you know this is like Friends of the
family the grandma
and she's from Germany and she's like
Jocko
I thought we were disciplined
and I said ma'am this is the freedom
part like you said right yeah like rich
just said you gotta have that discipline
said occasionally when that ice cream
cake shows up with the with the ground
up kind of Oreo scenario on the bottom
you know what I'm talking about yes you
know what I'm talking about right they
make the crust of Oreos type thing yep
they did the right thing yeah they did
they made good moves across the board
mint chocolate chip ice cream in there
so yes we have the discipline it'll give
us freedom ultimately to do what we want
that's what that's what we want was the
tagline you added on uh discipline
equals the freedom to be undisciplined
once in a while there you go yeah I
guess I put I put freedom in on
discipline in the same category right in
a way
so there we go uh discipline
next one
um open-mindedness a willingness to
consider and accept new ideas opinions
or perspectives
this is again coming from that book the
psychology of military incompetence
this is the major downfall of leaders
that have authoritarian mindset is their
mind is closed they don't hear your idea
not only did I want to hear your idea
they don't want to hear the Intel report
that just came out that's saying
something they don't want to take the
feedback from the guys that are on the
front lines that's how close-minded they
are and this causes all kinds of
problems it does and I you know it's
funny I put open mindedness specifically
in the book to speak to Optimal
Performance there's another attribute
called curiosity which I don't talk
about in the book and the difference
between the two is is really a an
activeness and a passiveness
curiosity is is proactive open minus I'm
gonna go whereas uh open-mindedness is
passive so that's you and I going to
Thailand and you know we meet our local
friend a local friend says hey I'm going
to take you the most authentic Thai
place and you're like cool we're all
we're like good good that's open-minded
or we go to Thailand we meet our local
Thai friend we say take us to the most
authentic restaurant right that's being
curious right and so very interestingly
these can exist independently right so
that you can be curious without being
open-minded you could be open-minded
without being curious being open-minded
without being curious that's okay okay
it's not too bad you're just passively
opened if you are curious without being
open-minded it can be dangerous as a
leader this is the seeds of conspiracy
theory right I know what I want to
believe and I'm curious to find out why
it's right right and um and the leaders
who are curious without being
open-minded stand the F by yeah
those are that's an interesting one
um
open-mindedness then can to some extent
be a debilitate
sorry deliberate process this is what I
like we just talked about this on one of
our other podcasts where I was saying
that having a contrary in mind
if you take into the stream obviously
it's bad and I've worked for bosses I'm
sure you did too they were contrarians
and so it just became a drag everything
was like well there's another way to do
this even if it didn't make any sense
we're still going to do a different way
but I like this idea of open-mindedness
making it a deliberate process and what
I said was being a contrarian it's going
to let you see the counter-intuitive
options that you might not see if you
didn't actively try and say okay let me
get deliberate about what's another way
to make this happen I just listened to
that it was I totally agree there's this
idea of The Devil's Advocate and I
always said hey I I really wanted the
occasional Devil's Advocate but it had
to be a productive Devil's Advocate not
a not a just a you know yeah yeah I'm
exhausting I had a boss that was very
contrarian on everything it'd look great
guy but you know eventually you're just
like yep got it yep wow that's crazy
boss wow that's nuts yeah cool can we
move on now right right
um uh next one you've mentioned this one
already cunning the ability to consider
and circumstances from unusual and
unorthodox perspectives in order to
achieve a goal or objective the story
that you tell in here is is uh pretty
cool and everyone on this podcast will
appreciate it because it's about Chuck
Liddell and basically you're talking to
some of your guys and who could beat
Chuck Liddell in a fight
and everyone's like kind of knows the
deal you know if you train combatives at
all you know if you go and this is at
the time period when Chuck Liddell was
the light heavyweight champion of the
world and so you if you've trained you
know that Chuck Liddell is going to beat
your ass
because he's way better than you are and
you've got one guy that's like I'll take
him
and everyone's like oh what do you mean
how could you take him and he says I'll
take him as long as I get to dictate
when and where we fight oh what do you
mean by that well I want to fight him at
2 A.M in the dark
in the ocean down at 50 feet and then
I'll take Chuck lidel makes sense yeah
that's your uh that's your cunning the
cunning mind um approaches a problem and
immediately asks three questions the
question it asks is first are there
rules and boundaries second is are they
real or are they perceived and the third
is if they are real what happens if I
break them and then goes about looking
at different ways and this exactly it's
one of the primary qualities of Navy
SEALs uh is the cunning mind as we we we
are not constrained uh by rules and
objectives yeah you have in here cunning
is a pejorative word implies sneakiness
deception using trickery to an unfair
Advantage but I'm using it a broader
sense as a neutral term
it might include deception at any given
time but not always rather I mean an
ability to disregard the unspoken and
often artificial rules when appropriate
to consider objects and circumstances
from unorthodox perspectives
this is a weird one in this day and age
okay so you're in buds
basic SEAL training and you I heard two
things when I went through buds one of
them if you're not cheating you're not
trying and the other one if you're
cheating you're only cheating yourself
and I've you know there's been obviously
you know buds is pretty high on the
radar
um as far as what what's going on there
but that's a difficult balance but there
is like there's no right answer you you
want to have guys are like wait a second
a classic example you know the
instructor will go out and say all right
uh you know you're doing log PT which
means you all you're you're on your
squad with six guys or seven guys and
you're carrying this log
and I think this is in this book
I don't know I read a lot of books is it
the one anyways the guys the instructor
comes out and says okay
take your team run down around the berm
and run back
don't do anything that I don't do just
do what I told you to do take your team
run around the berm and come back
and so all the teams pick up their logs
and run and one one leader says all
right let's go guys and leaves the log
because they didn't get told they had to
take it
so that's a person that's like thinking
outside the boxer good job right good
job and I think you talk about in this
book is the the dragon right yes go go
rescue the dragon who's guarded go
rescue the princess who's guarded by the
Dragon
and what the seal mindset is well can we
just avoid the dragon completely like
well how can we just not even have to
deal with the dragon Go
you know deliver a pizza to the princess
and then sneak her out
throw some slices of pizza at the dragon
too and he's all good as opposed to
going to fight the dragon where we take
Ashley's
um so that what do you what do you think
what do you make of that balance that
they look for in buds of someone that's
going to break the rules without
breaking the rules yeah it's so so Hank
and I talked about this uh we're having
coffee and it was actually in the
context of the the recent controversy of
of um of the students at steel training
using using substances and and in the
the common uh thoughts for most of us is
like that's we feel like that's still in
Valor right I mean if you're not going
to do it the way you're supposed to do
it then that's stolen dollar and but
there's a reason right because this is
different than cheating and what we came
up with right or wrong but like your
thoughts is that
if you're cheating and it's hurting the
team
it's bad right if you're cheating in the
context to get the team to accomplish a
mission right that's different right and
what what we what we were looking at in
that conversation about substance abuse
is you're you're doing you're you're
cheating the you're cheating the process
by which we will understand that you can
go to combat with us and do anything we
need you to do right because you're
you're giving yourself physical stuff or
whatever you're doing right
um so so you ain't cheating you try
you're trying is about is about looking
at the problem differently
for the purpose of making the team
successful and there's no selflessness
involved with it right and I think
that's the key
um again there's benevolent cunning
right that's that's Oscar Schindler
there's there's malevolent cunning right
that's Bernie Madoff I mean so so so
even being
um uh divisive or or devious right you
can do it in a benevolent way and these
guys who I would be curious I mean the
guys who ran around the berm without the
log they probably got beat up because
you know the instructor's like but they
probably you know the instructor's
probably got actually that's a pretty
good idea right yeah because they're
seeing they're seeing some different
ways of thinking as long as it's in
service the team selfish cheating is
where we draw the line
I was at Team two
we were doing CQC at whatever black
water is now called hey I can't remember
it's changed and they had this one of
this one of the mount towns they had
like a facade one one side of the street
was just a facade so there was only this
there was a street a fake Street and
then there was like a Hollywood for you
Echo Charles like the front of buildings
but they had windows and doors and all
this stuff and we had some Target that
we were supposed to hit where we had to
like go right in front of that street
and the few runs that we'd done already
the guys were hiding in those facades
and just shooting the [__] out of us
so you know we're just doing quick
iteration runs and I'm like all right
here's what we're gonna do and we moved
a few guys like the bulk of the platoon
just ran right down the field to the
Mount town and started doing the
clearance towards the target but we sent
like four guys ran all the way around
the berm all the way around to the back
of the facades and as we initiated the
target they just shot all the top four
in the back
and it was one of those things where the
where they were like hey good job guys
like hey you you we weren't watching our
six and you you kicked our ass they were
stoked about it so I the the what I
wrote down was like that theory of uh
kind of like the spirit of the rule like
if you break
I think there's something where you have
to judge like wait a second are we
actually doing something that's breaking
the spirit of the evolution like in buds
you know hey are we doing something that
actually is
is just not the right thing right at the
detriment of the team or at the
detriment of of true training right I
mean you know there's yeah yeah and what
I thought you were actually gonna say
when you were talking about you and Hank
talking about uh doing steroids or
whatever in buds what I thought you were
gonna say and I I agree with what you
said but also
if we're in a boat crew
and I'm on steroids and you're not I can
go a little bit faster and now you're
having to keep up with me and you're you
don't have the benefit of being Juiced
to the gills as they say which is a
problem now I I mean
from what I understand
the the the steroids as a whole are not
going to help you get through buds no
and it's going to be a detriment yes so
hopefully uh guys are hearing that
message what baffles my mind is the guys
who are doing it they haven't got it
because it's not about looking good it's
not about winning it if you can win
everything great yeah yeah it's a even
if I mean there's no score I mean the
guy who wins nothing but still makes it
through still becomes a Navy SEAL what I
was thinking about what you said earlier
is like hey you can do let's say you and
I get dropped down I'm Juiced to the
gills and you're not cool you did 117
push-ups before you've went face first
you hit the surf I did 130 right I did
an extra 13 push-ups no one knows no one
cares we both end up wet I cooled off
faster faster I saw my buddy who's
running goes in first phase told me a
story he said it was hell week and they
were doing this Evolution hell week I
can't remember it's called it's called I
think it's called a double up where they
run they have the class run two miles
and then when when they have a certain
time to do it and to whoever fails that
time has to do it right right do it
again or immediately do another two
miles and he said um this class it was
this class they were basically
apparently they they gotten word and all
that stuff they're they're super
prepared right they go to this two-mile
run they every single person passes
they're just like holy crap every single
except one dude and this dude is like
way far behind he's like struggling and
so the whole class passes and they're
sitting there and the dude finishes and
they're like okay you know um tell this
dude who's
um who didn't pass okay um you know go
go over there get some water you're
gonna do it again so he walks over to
the class
class kind of circle them huddle around
them
about a minute later the kid comes back
to the instructions hey uh I'm quitting
I'm gonna dor right so he quits and so
my buddy goes to the the class leader
and says hey uh you know what went on
there it's like well you know we I don't
know he just he we were all prepared to
win that and you know he um you know he
didn't he didn't live up and we kind of
we felt like it was probably his time
he's like my buddy's like calm
you guys are idiots it's like what he's
like you guys could have been sitting
around doing nothing while he ran
another two miles you know did you ever
think about that one now you're gonna
get a Beat
so this is this is thinking outside the
box right in a different way right so
it's it's this idea of are we breaking
the paradigms of our thinking because
this is what spec ops was designed with
her space and this is how we we we
conducted the War I mean I remember we
were changing tactics all the time to
try to stay ahead uh because you know we
had to you know and so I think the
cunning mind used benevolently and used
in service to others is a huge asset
yeah
um
definitely what what what the SEAL Teams
and like you said well that's what
Special Operations is
four yeah you know to look at a problem
and say hold on a second what were those
three questions you had those are three
good questions yeah first question is
are there rules and boundaries uh second
question are they real or are they
perceived third question is what happens
if I break them if they are real what
happens if I break them that's cool
those are good uh Echo and I just did
four podcasts about the game game yeah
we're just about the game about the all
the different games that you're playing
and life is a game and job as a game and
Jiu Jitsu is a game and relationships is
a game all these things but those are
three really good questions and and we
actually ended up talking about the
infinite game versus the finite game and
I know you mentioned that in here as
well but yeah
always checking things out and saying
wait a second
you know why are we even doing this
that's kind of the contrary in mind that
I have was like why are we even doing
this what what if we don't do this it's
healthy skepticism I think that really
is is a valuable asset healthy
skepticism powerful
um now we get into the this one the fun
one yeah you mentioned this one
uh It's All About Me by the way a
closing line of the book leadership
strategy and tactics is
it's on you but not about you
um narcissism the desire to stand out to
be noticed to be recognized
when I was lying on a California beach
in the dark the cold Pacific surf
crashing over me at the miserable height
of hell week I was not driven by
selfless service to my country I did not
lean on my deep patriotism and I was not
inspired by a sense of sacrifice or duty
to be honest none of those high-minded
ideals were even the primary reason I
wanted to be a Navy Seal in the first
place all those are part of me but of
course all those are part of me of
course but they aren't why signed up for
buds training so why did I for the same
reason every seal does to see if I could
be a badass special operator to prove
that I was good enough Tough Enough
strong enough to be recognized as a
member of an elite Fraternity in a word
I was motivated by narcissism
that's another one of those words that
typically is considered pejorative an
excessive amount of narcissism in fact
is clinically recognized personality
disorder but in the Layman's version of
the term narcissism is one of the
elemental engines of human behavior the
innate attribute that urges us to strive
to succeed to be noticed in healthy
doses it's important for Optimal
Performance
I got a I got a copy of the DSM-5 which
is the psychological Bible because I
want to make sure I was looking at this
correctly as in the DSM-5 they have a
couple pages on narcissism and and the
disorder and they have nine criteria in
there that you read like sentences and
the idea is if the if the doctor reads
these nine and five and the patient you
can say yes to five or more then the
patient is is considered disordered
right
and so I started reading through these
nine and as I read through them I did
not have five or more but I was not
innocent of all that I was reading and
so I said okay
I asked myself the question why did it
become the scene in the first place and
it was because you know all those things
exist but I wanted to see if I could do
something very few people could do
um and the idea and the the other thing
is when you look at the neurology the
Neuroscience of this uh an infant that's
getting recognized and adored by its
parents is getting bursts of dopamine
serotonin and oxytocin all very powerful
feel-good chemicals right it feels good
to be recognized and noticed doesn't
change when we're adult so so the the
the thesis is
um it's the impetus to some very
audacious goals that we set for
ourselves it has to be metabolized in a
healthy way and the way we metabolize it
in a healthy way is we surround
ourselves with people who tell us the
truth you can always tell the disordered
narcissists because they surround
themselves with yesmen people who tell
them what they want to hear people who
put them on a pedestal and it's
interesting because those groups are
very transient so someone who can't bend
the knee for very long will leave
eventually well that person who just
left immediately becomes Enemy Number
One to that narcissist that's just the
way it works and so so we can set so you
know a lot of people would wouldn't
argue that act and you we could debate
this but that Hollywood is generally
considered a narcissistic uh town but
you look at some of the the most kind of
the the healthiest most stable Hollywood
actors and actresses
um they are people who've surrounded
themselves with people who they're just
normal around right and so and so we
just surround ourselves with people who
don't put us on a pedestal who tell us
the truth who keep us humble that's our
teammates by the way that's our wives if
we marry the right person
um and we can really use narcissism to
create Advantage because why else would
I want to be an ABCO why else would I
want to write a best-selling book why
else would I want to be the best surgeon
the best athlete the best teacher
whatever that is
um so the idea is understand our
humanness recognize our humanness don't
don't ignore it don't pretend it's not
there just recognize it and body it and
try to metabolize it
say this
people who fall too high on the
narcissism scale however can be
dangerous in a simple sense those more
narcissistic types favor the quick hits
of Serotonin and dopamine over the
longer lacks lasting oxy what is it
oxytocin oxytocin
they need those constant reinforcements
because their self-esteem is either very
fragile or very low despite presenting
as arrogant they generally feel unsafe
and insecure they're extremely sensitive
to perceived injuries from criticism or
defeat and they very easily feel
humiliated or degraded to prevent that
highly narcissistic people try to put
themselves at the center of small tight
sycophantic tribes
they are rarely loyal
loyalty requires trust and a sense of
safety so their tribes are inherently
unstable healthy members tend not to
stay long and new ones that are let in
only when they show the requisite
deference those who do leave usually
suffer a disproportionate amount of
wrath from the person to whom they once
deferred because defectors are
considered enemies
so beware the highly narcissistic people
in your sphere their energy and effort
will more often than not be to prop up
their fragile egos rather than to
achieve shared objectives or serve a
common purpose they are by definition
not team players
yet if they sense you are distancing
yourself if you are not obviously on
their team they'll likely lash out
diminishing you in an effort to inflate
themselves worst of all narcissism
doesn't show up clearly in the mirror
the more narcissistic a person is the
less likely it is that they'll recognize
that behavior
this is one of the biggest um
things that we try and teach you know as
one of the key components
the most important characteristic for a
leader to have is humility and the
reason that we the reason that I found
that we have to lean into that
is because
when you're working with people that are
in leadership positions the tenant they
got there because they have confidence
right they got there because they not
only did they have confidence
they did well and were rewarded and when
they got rewarded they did even better
and then they get promoted and then when
they get promoted they're confident so
they do well again and so they get this
so we have a tendency when we're working
with and it was in the seals like
occasionally
we would have a young officer that was
over indexed in humility like just
lacking confidence right occasionally
that was way more often than not it was
someone that was you know hey I already
know how to do this hey I don't need we
did this my way like that was the normal
and it's the same thing in the business
world like you don't become the CEO of a
big company
because you are overly humble you got
there because you were confident and
then the more good decisions you make
and the more success you have the more
that ego gets out of control and that's
when we run into problems so uh that's a
good one yeah and honestly like
confidence I I almost tend to sometimes
separate confidence because I I consider
arrogance the opposite of humility um
and confidence interrogance the way I
talk about those when I when I talk
about organizations is um is arrogance
is our confidence is I know I can do
this arrogance is I'm better than you
um confidence is is internally focused
and arrogance is externally expressed um
and so obviously confidence is quiet
arrogance is loud arrogance almost
always comes from a place of insecurity
and so and so you can have a very very
humble you can have a very very
confident person who's very humble right
I mean most of the Masters out there
that we we've we've we've encountered
are very confident but also humble and
humility in my in my mind is really just
a it's not a it's not a deference it's
really just an understanding that I
always have something to learn I always
I have I I oh there's always someone who
can teach me something and I'm
open-minded to do it I'm not necessarily
right that's right yeah that's right and
so uh and so so people so so a lot of
these a lot of these folks again if you
if you look at the studies a lot of the
top like entrepreneurs like the very
successful they're a little bit higher
on the narcissistic scale but it's
because those Endeavors required a
little bit of that to get it going kind
of kind of to spark that but if you want
to keep on going you just have to manage
it yeah and that can bite them in the
ass too you know we see these people you
know self-destruct because yeah it takes
a level of confidence leaning towards
arrogance to get to like hey I'm gonna
take this money from you and I'm gonna
kick ass and we're gonna create this
thing that's never been done before I'll
tell you you Gotta Be You Gotta Have
Some level of arrogance pushing in that
direction but then they grow to a point
or they get to a point where all of a
sudden I'm not listening to you I'm not
taking like I said before I'm so
confident in what I'm saying I'm now
into arrogance now I'm not listening to
my advisors I'm not listening to them
Market hey people just don't know what
they want you know what I mean yeah they
just don't know what they want I'm gonna
educate them that's when you have people
just self-destruct which is uh
always crazy to see and unfortunate all
right time to roll into
the leadership attributes leadership is
not a position it's a behavior and you
don't get to decide if you're doing it
well I really like that you don't get to
decide if you're a good leader or not
leaders are identified and defined by
Those whom they lead you can't declare
yourself to be a leader that's like
announcing that you're funny
you might thank you you might think so
but if you can't make anyone laugh
you're not funny whether you're actually
a leader not just a person in charge is
entirely up to other people
um great leaders we're told again and
again are trustworthy they listen and
they care they're selfless authentic and
accountable
some of those answers describe skills
listening for one is greatly
unappreciated skill but most of them are
attributes
there are five that are key to
leadership empathy selflessness
authenticity decisiveness and
accountability
certain skills like time management
delegation and listening will enhance
those leadership attributes but they are
not critical in fact Mastery of any
particular skill is not required
so here we get into these leadership at
attributes the first one empathy the
ability whether deliberate or not to
join the emotional state of another
person to feel what someone else is what
someone else feels
definitely important I think it is and
um and overlooked quite a bit I mean you
know I I always Define
um Team guys especially team Team guide
leaders but I think team guy
holistically holistically as as the best
guys having kind of an empathy dimmer
switch so we know when to dial it up and
when to dial it down and this just stems
from this idea that we were out out
there doing combat and in one second
you're you're killing a terrorist and
the next second you're caring for you
know mother and kids right so it's a
it's a dial but
um but if we don't as leaders
take a take the time to feel what other
people feel then they will not feel
cared for if someone doesn't feel cared
for they don't look at you as a leader
what's interesting about these
attributes is that you know when I got
out of the Navy so a good friend of mine
Simon sinek uh author he linked me up
with a great leadership organization
called the Chapman uh uh the Chapman
leadership uh Institute so I went around
teaching leadership and kind of their
style and things like that and we'd go
around the country around the globe and
we'd get in front of these audiences we
say just ask a question what do great
leaders do and we'd have a flip chart
next to us and we just have people yell
out things and we just make a list of
about 25 30 things
no matter where we went the list was
always the same stuff always it doesn't
matter what country what what state what
generation it was always the same stuff
and always within the top 10 were those
five were those five things selflessness
accountability empathy empathy a lot of
times was number one you know or number
two so
um so it matters to to take that time
and it does take time it does take
effort but when you expend time and
effort that's also a display of caring
you know a good friend of mine used to
say time is the currency of leadership
because everybody has the same and and
when it's spent you can't get it back
and so when you when you spend time to
help another uh they will feel cared for
so yeah and then even the pragmatic
perspective of understanding what other
people's perspectives are and it's so
important like if we're gonna plan a
mission and you work for me
and I see some kind of resistance like
you don't want to do it or you've got
some some qualms about doing it like for
me to actually say wait a second what
does he see that I don't see it yeah
what does he know that I don't know even
from a pragmatic perspective that's like
tactical you know empathy about what are
you actually seeing is is so important
and and I always tell people you know
I've got a
I talk about not making emotional
decisions you know don't make emotional
decisions obviously and I always ask
groups of people you know who who in
here has made an emotional decision
everyone raised their hand who has made
a good emotional decision everyone's
hands goes down so we don't want to make
emotional decisions at the same time
you have to put emotions into the
calculus of the decision that you're
making yes so if my team is mad
I need to think about what we're doing
if my team is upset about something if
they're overly aggressive mindset I've
got to take those emotions into account
when I'm making a decision about what
we're going to do so it's not totally
void of emotions but you've got to
understand what other people's emotions
are understand what their perspective is
and that's what uh that's what empathy
is all about well and one more quick
note and this is really important
empathy does not require agreement
um and and we have to understand this
and our country could do do right by
understanding this so here's an example
um we were in Iraq
and uh we saw an unfortunate event that
that happens unfortunately too often it
was like a 12 or 13 year old kid
attempted to fire a rocket propelled
grenade at a convoy and and you know
unfortunately got got killed doing so
because they can't have that happen and
I remember a bunch of us Team guys at
the end of the day were around a fire
like we always do out over overseas
we're on the fire just chatting and this
thing came up and we we kind of said
well let's let's walk this thing back
for a second you know this kid
12 13 years old he probably has no
father so father's probably gone or dead
he's probably him just taking care of
his mom and his sisters no school no
loud music no Sports no parties no girls
nothing to get his testosterone out on
one day the bad guys come and say we
will give you a hundred dinar to go fire
this rock of a protein Aid at this U.S
Convoy every single one of us Navy Seals
said we would be that kid if we had been
in that environment we would be that kid
right that is empathy right and that's
empathy without agreement we don't agree
with what the kid's doing or what the
kid did but we can totally put ourselves
in that person's shoes and so so the act
of empathy does not require agreement it
really just requires effort
well that also reminds me of you know
when I was in the leadership position in
a seal platoon or a sealed task unit
I would look at these guys these young
seals that are 20 21 22 23 years old and
who do some knucklehead stuff yeah
and I would always remember yep ah that
was me I was that kid you talk about
being that kid that's right I was that
kid so that uh just remembering where
you came from and remembering where
other peoples are people are and
understanding where they're at and
that's what that's what this why this is
so important
um
such an important attribute for leaders
to have for sure
selflessness
placing the needs and well-being of
others
above one's own despite real or
perceived risk you know I had this I was
a
podcast without Jordan Peterson and and
what I ended up saying was I forget what
led to the conversation but I was trying
to explain what made a good seal
and you know I explained the fact that
look you can be a great shot you can be
a fast runner you can be a great diver
you can have all the parachute skills
but if you are the type of person that
doesn't put the team first no one wants
you in the platoon right period
um and that's exactly what you're
talking about here
yeah and there's a difference uh because
another attribute is generosity and we
have that in our in our kind of a full
attribute list but there's a difference
between generosity and selflessness and
the the difference is that risk factor
right generosity is can be done without
risk and that's fine it's great to be
generous selflessness is at risk there's
you're putting yourself at risk in some
way and when people see you doing that
they they tend to say this is someone I
want to follow yeah there's a whole
theme that I've been talking about for
the past couple years when it comes to
building relationships with people what
is a relationship can consist of well if
trusts you know if I trust you you trust
me we have a relationship if I respect
you and you respect me we have
relationship contrarily if you don't
trust me or I don't trust you we don't
have a relationship if I don't respect
you you don't respect me around a
relationship if I if you don't influence
me at all and and you're not influenced
by me at all we don't have a
relationship I mean if we have a
relationship we should influence each
other and the last one was listening if
I don't listen to you and you don't
listen to me we don't have a
relationship but the the final one which
I just added the other day and it's one
of those ones that was so sitting in
front of my face that it I didn't say it
and that's of course
care which you know we've mentioned
which is but the interesting thing and
this kind of reflects on what we're
talking about for every one of these
if I want you you to listen to me how do
I make that happen I listen to you yes I
want you to treat me with respect I
treat you with respect I want to be I
want you to be influenced by me I better
allow myself to have an open mind and be
influenced by you and the caring of
course
if I take care of you
in most cases you're going to take care
of me look if you're a narcissistic
bastard or whatever there's always going
to be people that you know I trust you
and you screw me over I listen to you
there's a small amount of people out
there in the world that are just all
their egos and they're they're just
dented dented Souls right they're
they're terrible people unfortunately uh
but for the most part
you take care of other people that take
care of you you you show that
selflessness and sacrifice and they'll
be willing to do the same thing for you
and this by the way is the only time you
can use leadership as the noun leaders
go first they go first in Behavior right
you model the behavior you want to see
more of and then you reward the behavior
you want to see more of if you want more
empathy in your in the people you are
that are in your span of care you model
empathy and then you reward empathy and
that's the problem if you don't
understand that you're not gonna because
people will automatically you know
they'll do what you where the rewards
you know flow and they'll they'll do
what the boss does right if they if they
if they feel good about it so that's the
only time you go first as a leader
so
uh next one here decisiveness the
ability to make decisions quickly and
effectively you say decisiveness is the
ability to make clear well-informed and
timely decisions the last Criterion
timeliness is what separates the person
with a high level decisiveness from a
person who merely makes solid decisions
in any Dynamic environment taking too
long to make even a good decision is
ineffective because the environment
changes so quickly
so
this is one that I've I wrote about this
one
in leadership strategy and tactics and I
talk about the fact that it I was
decisive in the SEAL Teams
but I always cheated and the way that I
cheated was I would make very small
decisions very quickly I wouldn't try
and figure out everything that was going
on that in the next four hours of this
of a scenario I would figure out okay
what's going on right now that I can see
and I can get we can make a move and I'm
going to do that pretty quickly
and then I'm gonna pay attention to the
feedback run that ooda Loop pay
attention to the feedback and make
another very quick decision and that's a
very I call the iterative decision
making process yeah lots of little
decisions quickly that's your
compartmentalization Loop going on too I
mean that's it's really effective and
one thing I do want to uh highlight here
and I I didn't say this earlier a great
way to determine whether something's a
skill or an attribute is to ask a simple
question that question is can I teach it
or can it be taught if the answer is yes
it's probably a skill the answer is no
it's probably an attribute so so someone
could come up to us and say hey I want
to learn how to shoot a pistol and hit a
bullet well we could take out someone
out to the range and teach them how to
do that in two hours right someone else
could say I want to learn how to be more
patient we can't teach you how to be
more patient and so to develop an
attribute you're low on requires a uh it
requires three things a a knowledge that
you need to develop it a motivation to
develop it and then a deliberate a
deliberate effort to step into
environments that test and tease and
develop that attribute so if you want to
develop your patients for example go
find environments that test and tease
your patients whatever that looks like
for you it could be I'm going to
deliberately go driving traffic I'm
going to pick the longest line in the
groceries we're standing I always say
have kids that'll develop your patience
right but the reason why I bring that up
is because I want to separate making
decisions with decisiveness just making
decisions is a skill you can actually
teach someone to make better decisions
and how they gather information it's a
skill that can be taught decisiveness
adds a speed and efficiency and a factor
to it and some people are just higher on
the decisive attribute than others but
but no it's it's rare I don't like to be
be definitive but it's rare that leaders
are looked at as Leaders if they are
indecisive there are some people I've
served with and served under who are
really great decision makers but it was
a long project to get them there was a
painful process you're like oh my gosh I
mean and again it just it didn't feel
like leadership you know it was wild uh
that you and I both got to experience
being pre-war and then living in the war
the the 96 hour planning cycle and that
was you know what we
I wouldn't say it kind of entered into
the scene in the mid 90s yeah it became
a thing where like this is and we
probably eventually caught that you know
it got passed down through the army and
eventually made it into the SEAL Teams
and eventually got into a freaking lowly
seal platoon where I was and it was like
help it's a 96 hour planning cycle
and man I remember my boss when I was at
Seal Team seven he's like how much time
do you guys need to launch on a mission
and you know he's like expecting I was
like 15 minutes
he was like what are you talking about
like I was like yeah 15 minutes sir and
I had a great relationship with my boss
until team seven I was like yeah 15
minutes will roll he's like how can that
be I was like tell me where the target
is tell me the friendly uh unit that's
in the area and what frequency they're
on and we roll and we can make this
happen
um big difference for the 96 hours when
I got to Iraq the first time we started
doing Ops I was so happy that that
because remember how many briefs it was
like you had to do like seven different
briefs and it was all like painstaking
when we get to Iraq and it's like hey
Khan up go and even the conops in fact
in fact that was actually a um a real
challenge in combating complacency the
speed with which we could move really
showed me and it made me really think
about okay we got to make sure that
we're actually thinking through things
versus just snapping on what we usually
do
um but all that said you know I just I
didn't like the 96 yeah you know for for
that you know the the way to combat that
a good little protocol to combat the hey
we got into a Groove and getting
complacent is just as often as I could I
would have my subordinates
come up with a plan like of you guys
here's the mission come over the plan
and that way I'm detached I'm looking at
it from a distance if they start
throwing it up there too quick or you're
just going to see the holes in it that's
powerful the other thing I was thinking
about when you're talking about teaching
skills versus
learning or developing attributes an
interesting uh metaphor that I use in
Jiu Jitsu or when I'm teaching a move in
jiu jitsu
let's say there's 10 things that you
have to do right to make a move actually
work in Jiu Jitsu there's 10 things that
you have to do
I can only teach you like five of them
maybe Dean Lister can teach you six uh
maybe a oh Echo can teach you four
doesn't have quite have it but there's
going to be things that you have got to
put yourself in that situation and
you've got to experience yourself in
order to get better at them so I think
that when you were talking about putting
yourself into these situations because
look I know for a fact and I know you do
too
I would see guys over time
improve in all these attributes
sometimes they would I should say right
not always right but sometimes you get
someone that is you know they're they're
just not very decisive they're just not
but then you'd see you put them in that
position you talk to him about it you
can tell them a couple things like hey
you need to hey figure out what three
things you could do and pick what's
one's the best one like even that little
help it's a move that you can teach them
that they can kind of start that can
become part of their personality and and
so you can teach some of it but
ultimately you've got to develop it over
time is that does that line up with what
you're totally lines up and and it
actually brings up a good point and that
is when we I kind of often uh relate or
relate to us as as like automobiles
humans are like automobiles we're all
different types right some of us are
Jeeps some of us are SUVs some of those
Ferraris and there's no judgment there
because the Jeep can do things the
Ferrari can't do and the Ferrari can do
things that jeep can't do but it
behooves us to lift our hood and figure
out what kind of engine we're running
with and there's no again there's no
judgment on that
um it also means that we don't
necessarily have to be high on every
attribute in other words I use stand-up
comedy right the stand-up comic who's
too high on empathy that could be a very
good stand-up comic right so it so being
too high may be detrimental to what you
want to do in your specific Niche
um but bottom line is when you start
looking at developing these things if
you find that you just can't develop
something that means you adapt and you
adjust I mean and they can start playing
off of each other so I think I remember
uh in fact I think I remember hearing
one of your examples on one of one of
the podcasts about talking about a guy
who was not uh I think he wasn't very
loud it wasn't loud yep wasn't loud
right
um and so and and you said hey you
encouraged this guy hey you got to be
louder and he just wasn't getting it so
basically he pulls the loudest guy over
and says hey tell the guys to do this
right that's adaptability he's using his
adaptability to buttress his low
whatever loudness attribute you know
whatever
um and and so you can some of these so
so for example
um low adaptability can be buttressed by
high open-mindedness right and you can
actually use that you can even out your
performance that way that's why
understanding these levels in in
yourself and your team is really
important yeah yeah
um
ah guy was that guy was a freaking smart
guy and did a good job I was like yup he
just solved that problem and that's why
building complementary teams when you
know what your attributes are and like
look I'm not the guy you want doing
paperwork right I always find the guy in
my platoons or my jobs that are good at
paperwork I'm fine that guy yeah I'm
gonna take care of him he's gonna be my
best friend because I'm not doing
paperwork right right
um next one accountability taking
responsibility for and ownership of your
decisions actions and the consequences
thereof
extreme ownership I agree with this very
much and by the way a buttress to
decisive this right you can't be
effectively decisive if you haven't
buttressed it with accountability
because you have to look at those
decisions and say okay was that the
right decision what are we doing did we
need to make a different decision so
incredibly important
um you're saying here in complex
environments take taking action is
Paramount even if the action is making a
decision to do nothing it's important to
understand what you're doing and why
just as important as recognizing that
any consequence
of that action any consequences of that
action are your responsibility you have
to fully own those decisions being
accountable and owning our decisions and
actions serves several purposes one it
requires that we understand why we're
doing whatever action we've chosen which
in turn helps us to be fully committed
to it
which I which
lately I've been talking about this
thing what am I calling it uh the
explanation effort meter the eem the
explanation effort meter which is
if it is if it is so hard for me to
explain to you why this makes sense I
should probably really consider if it
actually makes sense or not yeah it
shouldn't be that hard
look I'm fairly articulate I've got a
good grip on what I'm trying to explain
and if I can't get through to you
there's probably something wrong with my
idea now look there's a chance that you
just have a big ego and you're you know
everyone loves their own idea the best
but if it's really that if my idea is
that much superior to yours I should be
able to explain that and articulate it
and you should probably end up nodding
your head and going yeah you know what
you're right and
if I'm expending all this effort trying
to explain something
and it still isn't getting Landing with
you and you're still not nodding your
head well then why
how much effort is it worth right
because let's face it you know I I've
explained this to many people you and me
arguing about how to hit a Target
when neither one of us actually knows
where the enemy is going to be you know
what they're how they're gonna be set up
what we don't we've got ideas
but they're gonna get a vote and so you
and I disagreeing and being combative
and finally I said you know what shut up
I'm in charge you do it my way and then
we're going on a Target where there's a
we have no idea what's actually going to
happen and you see this in in the
business world too right people want to
make an investment in this thing over
here
this other person doesn't want to make
that investment the reality is no one
really knows what's gonna happen
and if I can't convince you you know if
that explanation effort meters just
redlined just all I'm saying is
just consider just consider maybe it
might not be worth the squeeze well and
the the hack to that the hack to that is
if you encourage or you allow someone to
make a decision to do something it it
automatically makes them accountable
right they own that in a way you know
the other thing I tell leaders all the
time because this is something that
sometimes they don't quite get is that
leaders leaders can always delegate
responsibility but never accountability
uh and that's really important because
I've had leaders who delegate both and
it's not good I mean it's not good they
they something goes wrong and and they
they back away they push away it's like
no no that's we're always accountable
now I'm not saying that you know because
some people are like well no the people
you're giving response they're
accountable to it yes sure yeah but you
are still accountable and by you owning
it it just it's the behavior you're
modeling that they need to see more of
they will also own it in their own way
but but we can delegate responsibility
we cannot delegate accountability yeah
another uh
another problem people run into and they
want you know if I want Rich to take
ownership so what do I do I say okay
rich
here's the mission here's the vehicles I
want you to take here's the people I
want you to take with you here's the
weapons I want you to use the rod I want
you to take the target they go through
the whole thing and say now now that's
the plan to take ownership of that plan
and go exit right it's like it's just
not happening one of my favorite
Metallica songs so one of my favorite
albums is Injustice for all one of my
favorite songs is um eye of the beholder
and the line in that is you can do it
your own way if you do it how I say yeah
exactly and that's like yeah take
ownership of this it's a song about a
pressures by the way it's awesome and
it's so easy to say hey man hey Rich
here's the mission how do you want to do
it right so much easier to say that I
don't have to get you to buy anything
into anything
and yes is there a chance that you
present to me a plan that's completely
insane it makes no sense sure yeah but
if we've been working together and I've
been showing you how we do this and I've
been letting you run little parts of the
operations prior to this you're gonna
know what to do yeah and you're gonna
give me a decent plan that we're gonna
be able to run with so
give ownership you go on to say here
purpose provides Clarity it's nearly
impossible to truly own an action if you
aren't clear why you're taking it if you
fully own your decisions you will better
be able to explain the reasons behind
them
being accountable allows us to look
objectively and critically at the
results of a decision which helps us
assess the results more accurately and
make the next decision more effectively
the mesh if the mission plan ends up not
working as well as possible the
accountable officer and men will
seriously figure out what could have
been done better rather than dismissing
any flaws as the boss made us do it that
way better decisions will be made next
time and everyone will improve a far
better outcome than repeating a cycle of
grudgingly doing what the powers that be
demand
finally taking responsibility for
decision and its results
immediately engages the learnability
attribute remember we human beings are
wired to make sense of our environment
while much of that happens automatically
and unconsciously part of that process
is very deliberate
so and this is where the uh the humility
comes into mind too because if you're
not humble enough to be like yeah this
was my decision and I made it and it
didn't work and here's what we got to do
fix it yeah well the other the last
thing I'll sit down on accountability
because I don't think I mentioned it in
the in the book is that uh especially
for leaders accountability allows
control it allows you to take when you
when you say
I own this and and sometimes I've done
this quite deliberately even though I
know I had nothing to do it I just take
it I say I own this this is my fault
right it I take the steering wheel as
soon as you place blame you're given the
steering wheel to someone else and so uh
so accountability allows for taking
control of an environment and starting
to steer it the way you want to steer it
Beautiful Life rule yeah a little little
extreme ownership goes a long way uh
team ability attributes is team ability
a real word team abilities a word I took
from nsw okay yeah although I think we
missed uh authenticity I think we missed
authenticity okay let's talk
authenticity the only reason why I need
to say it I need to mention is because
uh the guy I talk about in that chapter
Brian McCabe um he's a deeply authentic
guy and he loves and has been to several
of your musters
this is the one that um you uh there it
is there it is sorry I missed it
um authenticity the degree to which a
person's actions are consistent with his
beliefs values desires despite external
pressures is this who you gave the coin
to yeah and he held on to it for like
yeah yeah that's a great story
um again get the book read the story
very cool story about the history of
giving coins and uh what they mean and
all that and this particular case is a
pretty cool story
um among all the leadership attributes
authenticity is the most important for
building trust authenticity by
definition can't be faked it can't be
copied there's no template no checklist
of external behaviors or attitudes that
are the model of authenticity being firm
and taciturn doesn't make one any more
or less of a leader than being easy
going and funny what matters more is
that is that person is authentically
firm or authentically easy going
the simplest measure of authenticity is
consistency
very very you know
so so important right and it's really
hard to fake this stuff like when guys
aren't authentic it's like really easy
to see and how I mean you've seen these
some of these folks uh you know and I
will I'll just say as an example because
I've seen officers uh who are you know
sticky sweet to the uh the senior leader
who comes and visits they're just like
like apple pie and then they turn around
they're tyrants to the people underneath
them it doesn't feel trust yeah
yeah that um
there's a you know that level of
vulnerability there you know like hey
you're not gonna know everything that's
okay and you always I always
um
to your point
like that's one thing that's interesting
about the podcast it's like dude you're
on here for long enough I don't know how
many hours we have of doing this but
it's a long time
the character playing the character
after a while man it's just a really
easy coming out so here's a interesting
story I was putting when I was doing
this attributes work I was talking to
buddy of mine he worked for one of the
agencies and one of his primary jobs was
to help people develop alternate
personalities undercover personalities
and I told them about the work I was
doing he's like Rich this is really
interesting because when we help someone
develop an alternate personality we
always make it consistent with who they
really are because what we found is that
even the best actors on the planet can't
pretend to be someone else for more than
30 days you know most of us can't
pretend for more than a few days right
we will always revert back and what I
tell uh people in in business is that
anybody can pretend to be anyone you
want for an interview process right
um but the idea is these attributes are
who we really are all right and if we
lean on these then our authentic self
comes out yeah I love telling people uh
intent has a smell
and so when you're when you got some
weird alternative agenda in the back
everyone can smell it and you don't
think they can smell it's a weird thing
you can throw a little deodorant on it
you try and keep a little distance but
everyone goes you ever know that the
person you're like something just they
actually say it you say something
doesn't smell right yes right something
doesn't smell right that's when you
sense that lack of authenticity and man
the boys can see through that [__] oh
yeah they look at them oh no no we're
not buying into this so yeah sorry I
missed that one
um I'm glad you were on it
and so what's the guy that came to the
muster Brian McCabe okay yeah a couple
times yeah right on yeah so we'll have
to get him to another one yeah yeah I'll
uh I'll tell him to let me know and I'll
let you know if he's coming so
those uh are powerful events did you
have a good time oh yeah he loved him
he's been I think he's been to two or
three right off we'll get him to another
one we can make that happen we have the
power
uh so now we get into team ability yeah
again I think I took that from the teams
I remember that being one of the
attributes uh for for seal candidates
yeah so um man that's important it is
and it's weird that some people don't
get that right like you're literally
joining the sealed teams yeah you may
think it might be an important thing to
[Music]
be a good teammate be a good team player
and this kind of falls back on what you
said about yeah you can't say I'm a good
leader 100 the same thing here you can't
say hey I'm a good teammate
uh team abilities about how well people
work and play together How Deeply they
connect and how effectively they correct
collaborate much like being a leader you
don't get to decide whether you're a
good teammate others will instinctively
make that assessment for you and they
will do so based upon how well you
perform and interact with them
uh number one of these Integrity the
ability to act in accordance with
relevant moral values and social and
cultural norms you pretty you get a good
um
you throw a good
test at people on this one this is the
one about the person that cheated on the
test is this that one yeah yeah tell us
about that little dilemma well I will
misquote The Dilemma but what I will say
is we have to remember Integrity
subjective
um in other words in accordance with the
group
um doing the right thing for a Cub Scout
troop is going to look different than
doing the right thing for an Isis troop
and I would submit and this makes people
uncomfortable when I say it so I will
say it right if you have a Cub Scout who
steals five dollars from his fellow
Scout and you have an Isis person who
runs into a building with a suicide vest
who's being who's behaving with more
Integrity in that situation the Isis
person in accordance with their group
and so so the reason why this is
important is because if leaders have not
defined what do the right thing looks
like the the group's going to sort it
out and we found this in the teams I
mean the team sometimes those those less
well-run groups
um uh loyalty will supplant integrity
and that's not right either and so and
so leaders need to be diligent about
defining what do the right thing looks
like for group four organization
behaving those ways right because if
you're not going to behave at your your
sunk as well uh and then that that will
Define the Integrity for the group
um the example that you put in here is
like a kid
is cheating on a test basically and you
see him cheating in a test and and then
you ask like hey are you the person
that's gonna tell on them right or not
tell you I think I said you've studied
your your ass off on this thing and you
see this kid cheating yeah and on his
cell phone yeah and so then eventually
you give the context of like hey so so
the kid cheated you studied hard he's
gonna get an A you're you know he's
gonna pass but you had to work for it
and then the teacher asked you like hey
I think that kid was cheating was he and
you put you ask the question but then
when you put context around it it's like
oh his mom is sick with cancer he's got
a this is the one test he's got to pass
he's already been offered a job as long
as he passes this test he's gonna be
able to get his mom on health insurance
and he hasn't had time to study because
he's been taking care of it's like all
of a sudden like oh okay I was an
[__] fertility yeah right yeah so uh
I always try and break it down just like
do what you say say what you do you know
like if I tell you I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna do it yeah you know
um
Integrity next one conscientiousness the
ability and inner drive to work hard to
be diligent and be reliable
um you give a story about here about you
know guy you again get the book because
he's got cool stories in here lots of
stories yeah it's a dense book so yeah
um conscientiousness matters in the
context of a team because it Fosters
Trust this isn't an esoteric concept no
trickery of brain chemistry it's common
sense and you understand it intuitively
think of the people in your life
personal or professional whom you trust
odds are most of them are Dependable
reliable and hardworking in one way or
another
it's fairly straightforward yeah that
one's fairly straightforward like and
and the interesting thing is if you're
one of those people you get more work
yeah oh yeah oh yeah totally what is it
the the what's the saying the teams here
uh no no no good deed goes on punished
because you're gonna get more Good Deeds
if you're a reliable team guy you're
gonna get more [__] to do yeah but these
team ability ones are fairly
straightforward I mean they really are
they're they're not rocket science and
the reason is because we all know what
makes great teammates I was about to say
yeah we all have to interact with people
that are cool and people that suck yes
that's right yeah
humility the ability to be self-aware
and transparent about one's strengths
and weaknesses humility is often
stigmatized especially in high
performance Arenas it can be seen as a
weakness or lack of confidence a modest
or low view of One's Own importance as
one dictionary puts it as an attribute
though humility means being transparent
about your weaknesses that's not the
same as false modesty or the occasional
humble brag but rather an honest
assessment of one's abilities that also
means being vulnerable admitting
weakness by definition requires
vulnerability but it's critical in the
context of team ability one of the
strengths of any High performing team
lies in understanding its weakness being
open about your own
weaknesses allows others to understand
where they can help boom yeah uh working
with people that are arrogant
gets old arrogance kills themes it
really does and arrogance much like
narcissism is like a vampire staring in
the mirror you can't see it in yourself
um and so so I always tell people be
aware of it yourself because we we're
victim of it sometimes
um and then if you are a leader and you
see it uh in your so actually
arrogance was always a trigger for me I
mean I just just hated I mean every time
I saw it just trigger and I was I was
actually with a buddy of mine his name
is Josh waitskin do you know Josh
waitson yeah yeah
um so Josh and I would have lunch in New
York a ton of times when he was still
living there and um and we were talking
about one time we were talking about
triggers things that trigger us and I
said uh I said oh it's arrogance for me
and he's like oh it's interesting he's
like when I see arrogance I immediately
think insecurity and as soon as he said
that it clicked for me I was like that's
exactly it and I recognize that I have
to approach arrogance with empathy you
know there's something about that person
that's causing them to want to express
the way they're expressing and it
changed my whole view of arrogance that
is so accurate I just had a conversation
with a client this morning and they were
talking about that and I was like well
this you know this is ego and he's like
well I think it's insecurity I was like
yeah well you're right it's insecurity
which then flares up as ego
uh just like the dichotomy that I talk
about here you say there's a sweet spot
on the humility scale and it's quite
wide but there is danger at either
extreme
in either too much or too little a lack
of humility often resembles arrogance
while that's almost always a byproduct
of fear and insecurity arrogance on any
team is detrimental it breeds resentment
stifles communication and as a result is
brutal in terms of results too much
humility though risks teetering into
meekness
which in turn can lead to inaction
deference in the support of empowering
others is necessary for Optimal
Performance but there are times when you
need to step up and be the alpha
you will be the expert in the room the
one who's been empowered by the
deference of others at which point you
will need to take charge and perform
with confidence great leaders understand
this balance they will defer until
they've squeezed every ounce of
potential out of their team but they
will not hesitate to assume control when
required
moreover an overabundance of humility
can also mask an underlying lack of
confidence a lack of confidence real or
perceived inevitably will begin to erode
trust which in turn will undermine any
team your own level of humility is
difficult to assess humility is a
strange thing sir Edward Hulse a 19th
century British politician once said the
minute you think you've got it you've
lost it
I love that quote yeah that's uh that's
a very good quote I've got a section in
uh leadership strategy and tactics where
I talk about leadership vacuum
and when do you step into the leadership
vacuum and and I talk about
giving it a little bit more time and the
reason you get and this could be like
like literally two seconds
but if you jump in when there's a
leadership vacuum as soon as it shows up
other people haven't seen it yet and
they're ready to resist it or they
already think they know what's going on
so I would always like there's a little
bit of confusion I hear like some
shouting some yelling like no one's
really sure what to do give it a second
and then they'll send you hear the quiet
that means well people are recognizing
it and then if you say give it that a
second say everyone you know get to the
ground floor right now we're gonna move
out everyone's ready to be led at that
moment right so that waiting that's why
I like that that uh when you said defer
until you've squeezed every out of
potential like you want them to try yeah
and they can't make it happen it's like
all right here's what we're doing yeah
that leadership vacuum let it let
everyone feel the vacuum and step in and
make a call that's what you got to do
well I used to tell my Jos I used to
call the irony of leadership right I
used to tell my Jos you're if you're
doing your job correctly you're working
yourself out of a job you're creating a
unit that can operate without you and
that takes humility and a quick story
about Hank and I we were out in Iraq and
we were talking about some of the stuff
and we said to ourselves you know if
we're talking about growing all our
leaders and if we don't um
if I don't do anything about it we're
not walking the talk and so we said you
know what we should do we should have
him we should send them on our op
without us and so sure enough we find it
off and it looks pretty pretty good
pretty easy right we're like tell the
troop hey you guys are taking this one
here uh Hank and I are gonna sit back at
The Jock and um and sure enough they go
and one of the one of the troop Chiefs
uh take or one of the troop uh one of
the team leaders takes the GFC position
another takes the trip Chief position
they go out of course it turns kinetic
and it's like stuff's going down
and Hank and I are sitting in the jock
and we're looking this and we look at
each other's like man if this goes bad
we're done like we are done you know but
it's about I mean it's it's it's it's
being humble enough to then have the
courage to grow your leaders I mean if
you don't if you're not allowing them to
do what they need to do and and make
decisions and and and and and and have
confidence in doing it without you
you're gonna you're you're you're you're
you're you're you're not creating a team
you know and and the other the
collateral effect of that was that they
got back and the team leader that had my
job the ground first Commander he takes
his headphones off and throws them at me
he's like I never often want to do that
again right because of course GFC you're
like you have like 5 000 things going on
um so they have an appreciation for what
you bring to the team as well right so
um but uh but it takes humility takes
courage and humility yeah that was uh
something I learned from my when I was
in my second platoon we had the
best platoon Commander ever
um best guy ever and like he took over
we were platoon Commander got fired and
he took over and like the first training
Mission we did he was like I was I was
at E4 actually
and he was like Joker you're running
this Mission I was like E4 he's like hey
you're the pl for this and I was like
and he me and another guy another Eve
another E4 he's like you guys are
running this we're like and totally
stoked but man we learned and that's
what I did from then on so by the time I
was on deployment everyone had run
missions our new guys had run Ops as
ground force commanders in training yeah
so when we get overseas like the the
young lieutenants were definitely ready
um that's what you got to do man and
yeah well there's two things that are
going on like man you just want to go
out there anyways
it's true it's true
um
next one humor
the ability to find the funny even last
one to laugh when times are tough humor
is a powerful attribute you build a
laugh find this sliver of funny amid the
tragic and the trying can be calming
comforting empowering and encouraging
we've all heard the joke that broke the
tension the one-liner that smoothed the
edge of fear the wise crack that
distracted us from nagging pain I just
had a vision in my mind imagine if they
put like imagine if they just were able
to grab a compilation you know they have
YouTube things that are like uh best
one-liner for whatever imagine if they
had like real Team guys [__] little
things were going sideways and people
are cracking the best it's what I miss
the most that's what I miss the most I
mean the the the stuff that guys would
say oh so uh so a friend of mine you
probably know him but anyway he's um he
was telling me I was talking about this
he's like you know we're on our way back
from an OP one time and uh we were in
the helicopter and the helicopter
started going down started like having a
malfunctioning and crashing we're
sitting in this helicopter and one of
the dudes looks at us and says well I
guess we're not gonna have to clean our
weapons tonight and everybody bursts I
laugh I guess like that's what I miss
you know it's that dark humor oh
freaking classic yeah
um
next section uh is about Dynamics
subordination which we already talked
about
um just the fact that as you put it here
leadership shifts wherever and to
whomever the leader needs to be at any
given moment those teams understand that
information challenges and obstacles can
come from any angle at any time
and they're effective meaning the teams
are effective because the teammate
closest to the problem can step up and
Lead
while the rest of the group defers to
that temporary leader yes
freaking decentralize command everyone
on the team's got to be a leader that's
that's how we absolutely want things to
go down
um
got us a little section here is called
the others everyone has all of the
attributes if any of the 22 I've
described seem unfamiliar
that you can't imagine that they're
wired into you trust me they are
remember attributes aren't exotic quirks
bestowed only upon Elite performers
their basic part of being a human being
in their Elemental but you might have
some that are like just as you use a
dimmer switch right some that are pretty
dim pretty pretty low might not might
need to light a fire on some of these
things yeah
uh there's three more attributes that
you will say you want to discuss
and you say these three are important
but they're also outliers none of them
fits into the dimmer switch model
because each of them has an opposite
that can't be ignored most of the
attributes can be measured on a straight
line that begins at zero if you have low
accountability or empathy or discipline
whatever the dimmer switch will be at
the bottom your level of accountability
can't go lower than that negative
accountability isn't a thing
but what if you have zero patience
what if you have less than zero patient
then you're impatient so you get into
these some of these patience and
impatience yeah the idea the idea was um
that these polarities uh can both imply
success uh so in other words the they're
highly successful people who were
patient they're highly successful people
who are impatient and and same with the
other ones and and the idea is on a team
this is when you this is when polarities
matter right the best teams have
representation on either side right and
my wife and I are a great example I am
typically a patient person my wife is
typically impatient right that's worked
beautifully in her 23 years of marriage
right because when patience has been
required I step up when inpatience is
required she steps up
um and so so whether it's patients or
inpatients um whether it's
competitiveness or non-competitiveness
which really was interesting because
I've never been a competitive person you
know even when I was captain of the
lacrosse team whether we won or lost
didn't bothering me very much in fact I
used to fake being upset because I was
like uh it would probably look bad if
I'm not if I'm not like swearing or
something I thought that would be a
detriment to me when I went to seal
train because like oh shoot I'm not
competitive but what I recognize is that
the competitive mind tends to think in a
finite game right it tends to place
rules and boundaries in an environment
because you can't win or lose unless you
have rules that Define win or losing the
non-competitive mind there are no rules
right we both know that combat or
military operations in fact any type of
teaming requires both Polaris sometimes
it requires running up the line and
winning right sometimes it requires
thinking outside the box and so those
are two and then the final two which I
thought were interesting I was really to
be quite honest trying to figure out
what it was about seals that
distinguished us and I was kind of
landing on this vanity piece I was like
is it vanity right and I was almost
going to use vanity but the problem with
vanity is Vanity
typically centers around appearance you
know and while we know there are some
guys who really focus on their
appearance it wasn't the other thing and
so that's why I kind of thought about
this fear of rejection thing and what I
recognize is this is it here this is it
because every single one of us who made
it through buds we have somewhat of an
elevated sense of fear of rejection we
don't want to look bad for our teammates
we just don't and it pushes us to do
things it pushes me to jump out of an
airplane 20 000 feet which I never
otherwise would have done right so that
can actually power you in certain good
ways obviously too much is bad too
little is bad but then the opposite
right the associates I don't care what
anybody thinks we've seen those people
right that these are iconoclasts they
start their own movements they're the
people who's like I don't care what
anybody thinks I'm doing this and
typically people start to swarm around
them so uh so my wife and I are like
this like I have an elevated sense of
fear of rejection she doesn't care what
people think and we we blend together
beautifully right so so these polarities
should be looked at as hey if you can
have each represented
high on either one is not a bad thing
have each represented and you'll have a
really balanced team yeah I'm just
paying attention to where you're at you
know a lot of a lot of well it's the uh
when someone's an alcoholic and the
first thing is like saying I'm an
alcoholic so so the first thing here is
saying like oh I have a high fear of
rejection I need to pay attention that's
right over into you can over index on
that you can over index on patients you
can over index on inpatient so having
that um
balance balance I guess we'd say now you
go into you know kind of getting close
to the end here of the book uh you've
got decoding your palette and what you
say is you've got a you've got a online
thing at the attributes.com and you've
got an assessment tool yeah I actually
haven't taken it yet uh but talk us
through a little bit through this tool
and then
how it works yeah fill this thing out so
the tool the tool is for the the first
three categories grit mental acuity
drive and the reason why it's the first
three is because those can be
self-assessed we we have just finished a
leadership and team ability attributes
tool
um that is going to be a three that is
the 360 because again you can't you
can't just assess yourself on how humble
you are right or how how selfless you
are so that's the most humble list
um the one on the website now is uh is
free uh for those three and you can get
a score and and the score really should
be looked at as a as a starting point
okay because whatever that score is then
the idea is to interrogate your own
performance and say okay if I'm coming
up low on adaptability let me think
about some environments where my
adaptability is tested the environment
was changing around me how did I do
right okay it was difficult it was
challenging okay that makes sense to me
um and so the assessment tools can allow
you some some sense on where you might
stand and where your dimmer switches
might lie and then it really takes some
self-reflection to uh to really get that
dialed in
um and then you've got This Acronym to
to start to make adjustments to these
things you've got This Acronym start
which is slow down think act recognize
results and try new environments these
that's the am I correct in saying that's
the methodology to actually start to
evolve and improve your attributes yes
because well I guess the the the the
part that comes before that acronym is
Place yourself in the environment where
the attribute is being tested and then
you're going to feel stress and
challenge come on so as you feel that
stress and challenge then you in then
you slow down you think you know you you
you assess your performance you can use
that acronym account it's like okay you
think again this is what we just talked
about you know engage your conscious
mind engage your frontal lobe to start
examining your performance in the moment
and you'll start to understand and and
develop it
um lots of good tools uh and I'm just
gonna fast forward just kind of close
out the book
um you say this and again this isn't the
closing of the book I'll leave that for
the people that get the book but for me
to close it out it says we are a species
that in only 10 000 years evolve from
cave dwellers to Space Explorers
humans have the unique and Brilliant
gift of being able to imagine something
and bring it into existence we are only
able to do this because of our grit our
mental acuity our drive and Leadership
and teamwork
understanding your attributes is one of
the keys to unlocking your potential
so that's you again that's my wrap to
the book it's not it's not the wrap of
the book but you know even there you got
to go back that's like going back uh
2500 years to Sun Tzu
um in saying that we have to know
ourselves and what you're saying in
there is like
we have to know ourselves and in this
case know ourselves through our
attributes
amen so
um
that's the book so you're working on
another book right now yeah so the next
one's called masters of uncertainty
which is really what I always Define
seals as individual and teams that could
drop into complex environments and
figure it out and um and I'm gonna I'll
lay it out in about six steps uh
Step One is understand your attributes
step two involves your identities the
identities we we Define ourselves step
three is our beliefs and that's kind of
understanding yourself because we all
all of us who do this habitually know
those three things about us and then the
the other three steps are in fact the
tools actually a lot of the stuff in tea
room and I have worked on the tools that
allow someone to actually engage their
own physiology to start stepping through
that and again it's about
um it's about a process right we can't
pre uncertainty by definition cannot be
predicted and that's not what we do
right it's like oh you seals you're
you're experts there no no we're experts
at the process right we understand when
when things go into chaos we slow down
we start working through the process and
start figuring it out and it's not
always pretty right sometimes it's
decidedly ugly
um but it's the process so I'm going to
see if I can get that kicked out here by
the end of the year how deep are you how
much have you written so far I'm about a
third in but it's gonna be a shorter I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a this is a this
attribute is a very dense book I'm very
proud of it but it is dense I'm going to
do a much shorter version so do a little
bit quicker so so you're a third done
what is it Tim Ferriss Tim Ferriss this
is such a great quote from Tim versus
you've written a book so you know this
is true uh when you're done with your
book you're 50 yeah that's right yeah
freaking nightmare I know no I'll say
I'm getting pretty good at this point
like when I'm when I'm done I'm feeling
like I'm when I'm done when I when I'm
done writing it I'm like I'm I'm almost
there yeah yeah uh so people
can find you like you do Consulting yeah
um you you do speaking
all that's through the attributes.com
yeah it was a One-Stop shop One Stop
Shop check out all that stuff uh and
there you also have social media yep
Instagram got Instagram you're rich
underscore Divinity yep you're on
Twitter yes do you engage on Twitter
much not much I I need to do more but as
you know we're I mean we it's it's
somewhat antithetical to our normal
behavior but yeah but yeah Instagram
Instagram mostly LinkedIn
um and then Twitter occasionally too so
and you have Facebook Facebook as well
yeah it's all on it and it could be all
found on the website so it's all there
at the attributes.com
and that's how people can find you reach
you talk to you
um and that's I don't know that does
that get us up to speed totally man this
is uh this is good good place to stop
Echo Charles yes sir
what do you got man questions from Echo
Charles
uh you have a your twin brother
identical oh that's right identical Echo
has a twin brother as well yeah so you
guys you guys want me to leave
a special twin Bond I kind of want you
to leave it uh is he involved in any of
this the stuff that you're doing he's
not he's uh he flew for 20 years and now
he flies for FedEx all right so uh but
you know he's he's still a best friend
so yeah um so you mentioned you yawn
before like a competition or nervous is
that a common thing I used to do that
too that's why and I thought I was like
the only one
you were just tired bro uh it's uh it's
literally it's it's accessing your uh uh
trigeminal nerve which is linked to your
vagus nerve and it's it's it's engaging
your parasympics parasympathetic system
so yawning is I've heard now that I've
written it's funny you read a book and
then people start oh I on too right so
I've heard of there's a bunch of people
who've gotten back inside you know I I
yawn as well so yeah because it's kind
of like you you wouldn't think that
right like if you're nervous you think
you're gonna be all right yeah you're
yawning so I'm like yeah I thought it
was weird yeah then I talked to huberman
and humor was like hey that's why that
happened thanks buddy there you go boom
the world makes sense yeah who's born
who's older you or your brother I am two
minutes two minutes older did you who's
bigger well after buds I was yeah we
were fairly we were fairly even he
didn't play lacrosse he played like a
year but um but we were fairly identical
and I went to Buds and yeah just I got
really thick was anyone born bigger were
you the same
uh we were basically the same yeah yeah
interesting this the he has two
daughters I have two sons so oh really
you beat the curse yes I did wait what's
the curse curses if you're in the single
teams and they actually say it about
Pilots too right
well the person the SEAL Teams you're
gonna have girls right for kids that's
the curse and it's and it's pretty
freaking it's pretty heavy it's a pretty
thick curse pretty effective curse yeah
is that an echo Charles yeah that's it
no more questions no twin questions you
know some secret code you gotta like
throw out there
[Music]
hey what's it like to be a twin and I
always say what's it like not to be a
twin
similar yeah yeah you don't know any any
different yeah so yeah some interesting
Dynamics can happen with twins right
yeah I would say so more or less
explainable I think but yeah I saw
something that if you are a twin and you
marry twins like you each marry Twins
then your children are
DNA wise brothers and sisters between
the whole crew yeah so in a way yeah
because they can't differentiate DNA
right so the yeah yeah yeah so that
would make sense is that math I guess I
didn't think I never thought about that
part of it but yeah I guess the
likelihood of you having twins goes up
too or something like that it typically
Skips a generation or it skips it yeah
it usually it usually Skips a couple so
so like
um my sons might have twins right
um it skips down so just who knows it's
just yeah I don't know we don't have any
other twins in our family I don't think
yeah that I know of black who knows
awesome Rich any any closing thoughts
Hey listen I just I first of all what
you all are doing and and and since you
began since since the day one I think
the leadership stuff has always been
sound like I told you I think it's it's
very simply put and digestible and I
think I I'm I'm always excited when I
can hear guys take
military experience and translate it
into ways that people can actually
understand it and it's not just I want
to sit and tell a bunch of stories
because the combat part is you know it's
it's tough it sucks right so we can
extract some goodness out of it so so
thanks for doing that and and thanks for
having me I appreciate it so I'm glad
I'm glad you're either I was thinking
about you know I knew you were running
train on the west coast and
um and some of the ways you ran training
that I heard was like well that's I mean
testing out I mean if a guys can't get a
run done before getting contact or
something's getting thrown into the mix
that is attribute training right you
know and I think that's uh so it's it's
it's exciting that you you read it and
it resonates good actually I have one
more question yeah do you know who Sam
Harris is right oh yeah I'm a big fan
okay has anyone ever told you you sound
like Sam Harris no but I consider that a
compliment yeah yeah like the so I don't
know what you'd call the tonality or
whatever but yeah every once in a while
no I didn't think there you go I found
that to be the case even with like
videos I've seen of you oh but even more
so in person do you know what ASMR is is
do you know what it is yeah it's like
yeah it's well it's like you can but
it's also just talking like this like
someone and it's uh it's like a weird
thing on the interwebs yeah yeah it's
like sensory and so sometimes they'll
like
yeah but anyways I was on Twitter when
Sam Harris used to be on Twitter which
he's not on Twitter anymore but uh and I
said something to him you know like oh
you know we're making fun of each other
which we would normally do and we I
don't know if you're on Twitter we Sam
Harris and I had a long running
um
war on Twitter of me challenging him to
intellectual debates and him challenging
me to fight oh that's hilarious and so
that was kind of our and then what's
funny is every time I'd say like you
know you're too scared to debate me and
then there'd be a bunch of people like
Aha and then do someone's like this guy
Jocko you're an idiot this guy's a
freaking like take it seriously and then
he'd chime back like he you you know
you'd love to debate so you didn't have
to face me on the mats right and so be
like what is wrong with you Sam Harris
you're an idiot
uh so anyways the long story short you
know he's got a very calm soothing voice
and I've made some comment about him
making ASMR but then it turned out that
everyone says that about him it wasn't
even it wasn't even new uh huh because
he does have a very calm calm yeah
that's why he's a meditation episode
great I mean it's uh it's very soothing
yeah
I sent him a book so I don't know if
he's ready okay so Echo puts you in that
category yeah uh locally or asmr-ish
maybe if the attributes doesn't work
I'll try that yeah there you go no one
has ever told you I have an ASMR voice
anyways man thanks for joining us
appreciate it appreciate you coming out
here uh you know more important thanks
to your service to the nation to the
teams
um you're in leadership your whole
career most of which was war so uh
thanks for going out there and holding
the line man ditto brother thank you
and with that rich Divini has left the
building
Echo pondering your personal attributes
you over there yeah would you come up
with well actually to be honest I did
more than Ponder just my personal
attributes I pondered like my kind of My
Life coming up you know how you kind of
reflect on like hey wait what why am I
first you first you started to think oh
what attributes do I have and do I lack
and then you're like why is that then
you think of your childhood and like all
this stuff where was I successful and
why and where was I unsuccessful and why
kind of a thing so it's one of those
it's a good reminder because the skill
part which it which dawned on me some
time ago kind of like a video game where
you can just especially nowadays right
you can just think of a skill and be
like I want that skill and you can get
it Go on YouTube yeah you exercise a
little commitment a little discipline
you can have that skill yeah it's
bullying awesome just like that you have
another skill I mean not just like that
but like you can have it in fact I'll
even go one more and you can you can
have one of these real like the Real
Deals life-changing skill in like three
three or four years example
like let's say I want to be a I don't
say lawyer but let's say I want to be uh
marketer maybe a web developer or a
coder like I want to code I want to do
coding now you know that's a hot like or
I want to make apps yeah or something
like this right do it yeah you three
years you wouldn't even need three years
I don't think video editing video
editing that's kind of that's actually
what you've done yes you can go to
college no you haven't even done a
course have you ever paid money
yeah I paid money for courses for sure
like skillshare but it's like a
membership to like skillshare for
example that's like a membership thing
so you can how much is it I don't know I
forget did you do it a lot no like I
took one percentage of your knowledge
came from that oh 0.1 okay so and it's
so glad you corrected
you get the attribute of being a dip
[__] right now
of being very specific and precise yeah
yeah anyway and it was for and actually
you know what you're even more right
than I kind of indicated because it it
wasn't for video editing it was for VFX
okay which is part of the video Pro
anyway
true true 100 what self-taught right you
don't need so anyway anyway the the
point is we think of skills as like
something that you know you can get
which is true it's even more true now
but the attributes is the thing that
what inform the skill as it were which
we don't I mean of course I think we do
think about that but we don't think of
it as something to pay attention to you
know where it's like yeah you can work
on your weaknesses and and that kind of
thing but it's like not in that specific
way it was a good reminder I thought
yeah and this ties into uh what we talk
about at Echelon front when it comes to
and if I've talked about a bunch of the
podcast like what is your tendency yeah
yeah as a person it is your tendency to
micromanage then you have to know that
about yourself if is your tendency to be
too aggressive you have to know that
about yourself is your tendency to let
your ego get in the way you have to know
that about yourself and if you can pay
attention to those Tendencies you're
gonna have a better chance of correcting
the issue and it's the same thing as
with these attributes if you know oh you
know I'm not really good at this
particular deal so I can a pay attention
to it hopefully improve upon it but also
get people on my team that
compliment my areas of weakness and the
part I thought is
and something I always like keep in mind
too about like people who keep you keep
around right like you you say don't have
like yes men or whatever it like this
kind of in a small way Illustrated like
how important it is like not to have a
yes man so which one he was talking
about something or some uh attributes
that are like vampires you can't see
them in yourself well yeah ego was so
yeah and I think a lot of them are like
that to different degrees narcissism
narcissism there's the ego there's like
even like being um the quote about
humility the minute you've got you the
minute you think you've got a humility
you lost it yeah yeah I'm the most
humble person in the world like no one's
more humble than me you know you know
coach Adam yeah hell yeah he's amazing
yeah he makes a t-shirt that says the
most humblest yeah kind of funny yeah
it's like the play onwards but if you
keep people around whether it be family
friends or whatever that are that that
will and if you indicate to their hey
I'm working on this part of it or
whatever maybe you know keep your eye
open for this kind of thing and they can
kind of help you with that stuff see I'm
saying so it's like a workaround for
them for the vampire attributes check
all right well while we're working on
our attributes which we will let's also
work on our physical
and mental
capacity to do more it's true in order
to get there I'm gonna have to work out
mentally physically
when you do that guess what
I'm going to need to fuel that system
and I recommend you go to jocofuel.com
get yourself some fuel it's true the
cleanest fuel you know you can get
different levels of fuel yeah at the gas
station sure oh yeah yeah like one's
premium one's okay one's like hey bro
fill up that Corolla
you know what I'm saying yeah they call
that the regular yeah so you want to get
the premium for your for your body you
want to get the premium and there's
actually a big difference like let's
face it you can put the you can put the
crappy fuel in your uh in your Mercedes
if you want to
you know they're gonna recommend against
it of course and you can put the good
gas into your Corolla
might be a waste of money I'm saying you
can get away with it in both cases with
your body though with what you put in
your body you want to go with the clean
the good I think so to cleans up doctor
fuel.com get yourself some protein look
if you got a drink an energy drink
don't just drink one of those energy
drinks don't drink one of the other
would you would you in your little video
you made would you put extra legit
yeah made by most drinks yeah
energy yeah yeah so don't drink that no
it's got a bunch of crap in it that's
gonna kill you
oh juggles being all great no you drink
that much chemicals that much sugar that
much caffeine it's gonna kill you
so don't do that
get yourself some Jocko discipline go
um
get yourself some ready to drink protein
yeah the ultimate
go-to fuel
so I got some elk meat by the way oh
nice and so I'm like okay yeah this is
some like the good stuff you know I make
up my little I got some recipes to tell
you about them later but yes perfect
right I have okay I got the 50 grams of
protein from the elk meat right then I
got the 30 grams with the drink yeah
they're ready to go oh man 80 grams just
like that boom all good you're good go
bad no catabolic going on there no sir
staying out of that zone uh joint
Warfare you train in Jiu Jitsu we talked
a lot about fighting today a little
decent amount about fighting if you're
doing physical stuff man doing Warfare
jockoffool.com you can get it there you
can also get a vitamin shop you can get
the military commissaries Hannaford
Dash doors uh uh Wakefern ShopRite HEB
Meyer up in the midwest something else
coming online
GNC heard of it the GNC bro rolling into
GNC old school yeah it's iconic do you
know specifically what's going in there
I will have to give you the actual
product list yeah but uh yeah I don't
have it right now on me because I figure
and I'm just oh the only reason I asked
because I I when I used to frequent GNC
from time to time I'd go in there for
specific stuff so it would be what
protein pre-workout
and any kind of vitamins yeah yeah
that's what GNC's for technically
everything you just said
but no the energy drinks not so much
right
I mean I would grab I would grab one if
it was nice but energy drinks is one of
those on-the-go things not a like oh I'm
shopping for some more supplements yeah
yeah but I guess it's a it's something
would you get fired up to go to GNC yeah
like a little bit of uh
of course
yeah and that was like back in before
online shopping was like super hardcore
like it is now it was yeah it was good
it was like a whole experience there's a
few stores that are like that where it's
like you don't just go there just to buy
it like a freaking
CVS or something like this you go and
it's kind of like the experience
GNC go check that out
um we're actually I think around the
20th when is this coming out I think
February 20th
2023 in that GNC go in there and just
buy just go and get some let's be like
get some get in the you know the old
thing you had when you were a kid and
you get a new pair of shoes maybe a
little bit faster
you know what I mean yes
do you ever have kids no I never had
kids so you had kids or you got the
converse one star you got a pair of
Chuck Taylors and then the Nike with the
waffle I had like the OG Nike with the
waffle tread blue and yellow okay roll
back in the day brother when Nike made
one shoe imagine that oh damn Nike made
one shoe it was just blue
shoe it had a waffle tread on it this
that was the name of this truck I
remember the waffle tread I don't
remember the blue shoes so blue with a
gold stripe
back in the day when you got those you
kind of like felt like you're a little
bit faster I remember that same thing on
a g and C back in the day like you're
gonna get a little bit more jacked
so roll over to GNC get yourself some
jocka fuel there we go also uh
originusa.com you're gonna need some
American-made look you're not you're not
looking to buy
these other companies aforementioned
companies that are you that are using
slave labor to make their stuff right
we're not doing that
we're not doing that we're not
supporting
countries that have tyrannical
governments we're not doing that we're
supporting America freedom
we're supporting the workers in America
we're bringing manufacturing back to
America all that right there you can do
originusa.com jeans boots geese
rash guards t-shirts hoodies wallets
belts boots
origin USA
Freedom that you can put on your body
yeah there you go we're in the Delta
68's current oh yeah that's right when's
the last time you wore a pants to record
the podcast well I've been wearing Pam
but I used to wear the kill like
camouflage phones I don't know if I've
ever worn pastoral caught a podcast I
didn't wear shorts bro bro it's not a
senior the uniform your uniform and it's
funny because you like take off your
slippers too yeah yeah it would be your
favorite food full-on Hawaiian style
yeah good man that's good
uh speaking of Hawaiian style speaking
of Hawaiian stuff um okay so Jack was a
store we're representing on the path
I know I am discipline equals Freedom
good there's a there's a good
version shirt on the shirt lock coming
out oh really it's just a hint it's been
a while little heads up it's a good one
it's a little bit more more like subtle
okay either way okay yeah you want to
represent jacostore.com also I mentioned
this shirt Locker which is the new shirt
every month some cool like new designs
every month people seem to like that one
but yeah look at that check that that
one out we I put on
um what do you call like a we call it a
sneak peek it's like a little close-up
of part of the design so you can kind of
get a hint of what the next design is
too if you want to check it out before
you sign up or whatever but nonetheless
go to jacostore.com I like it subscribe
to this podcast subscribe to Jocko
underground we do what we do about a
podcast a week on Taco underground the
ug as it's called
and that way we can talk about whatever
we want and uh we have a Escape platform
in case we get shot down for whatever
reason you know we'll be there 8.18
cents a month if you can't afford that
it's cool we still got your freedom
email assistance.com underground.com
don't forget the YouTube channels don't
forget psychological warfare don't
forget flip side canvas don't forget all
the books attributes by Rich Divini
don't forget about that one and then all
the books uh only crying for the living
final spin all the leadership books the
way the warrior Kid books
what a opportunity to make a kid's life
better make their whole life better by
the way yours Mikey the dragons about
faced by hackworth I wrote the forward
on the new one there you go a bunch of
those books Echelon front we saw
problems through leadership
astronautfront.com don't forget about
our online training platform extreme
ownership.com this is how you get better
at life
you don't get better life by you read a
book one time now you're good or you
went to a seminar one time or you
listened to one podcast no you gotta
interact
so go to extreme ownership.com take
classes ask questions live interactions
with me with life with the team so we're
doing and if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their families you want to help
gold star families check out Mark Lee's
mom mama Lee she's got a charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go do America's
Mighty Warriors dot org
and also don't forget about Micah Fink
Who currently at this time we just got
reports from the field he just killed a
mountain lion
with a k-bar knife
he is skinning it and making a loincloth
which he will wear
on a 72-day retreat across the
Wilderness
microphink getting after it uh if you
want to connect with us on the interwebs
don't forget Rich Divini to get in touch
with him or what the services he offers
go to the attributes.com and on social
media rich is on Instagram Rich
underscore Devinny Twitter at richdavini
Facebook richtavini of course Echo and I
are there as well Echo is uh Echo
Charles
I am at Jocko willick be advised the
algorithm's there it's waiting to grab
you so just you know look out thanks all
the military personnel out there on the
front lines maintaining Freedom around
the world we appreciate what you're
doing right now and also thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders you maintain our
safety for us here at home we are
grateful for that and everyone else out
there
know your strengths
know your weaknesses know your
attributes
know yourself
then
see where you can get better and be
better by going out there every day
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out